Endlich Leine ziehen im Kampf gegen Rihanna, habt ihr jämmerlich versagt.
Britney Spears, Celine Dion sind euch überlegen.
Die Black Eyed Peas laufen über all den ganzen 60.000 Fonds.
Ist jetzt die B.
So Leute, haben wir Quality Options?
Haben wir Quality Options?
Poggas Quality Options.
Die Ärzte sind jetzt auf Spotify, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Auf Spotify, auf Amazon Music und auf Deezer oder so, hab ich noch nie verwendet.
Irgendwie spackt meine Vorschau.
Jetzt geht die Vorschau, sehr schön.
Und Quality Options am Start, ist ja geil, gleich beim ersten Anlauf.
Sonst muss ich immer 3-4 mal neu starten, bis es bei Twitch funktioniert.
So, wir machen noch da weiter, wo wir gestern aufgehört haben.
Wenn ich weiß, um was es geht, Ausrufezeichen HR-Tool.
Hat nichts mit dem Hessischen Rundfunk zu tun.
So, in dem Fall steht HR für Hardware-Rat.
So, jetzt muss ich ein bisschen leiser.
Wie macht man das jetzt eigentlich?
Open Volume Mixer.
Ich finde es so, wir mittlerweile, wo Einstellungen versteckt sind unter Windows.
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen muss ich jetzt hier rüber switchen.
Darf ich jetzt hier leiser machen?
Okay, ist auch witzig.
Edge darf man nicht, die Lautstärke steuern.
Verwendet wahrscheinlich Microsoft irgendwelche geheimen Sonstwas-APIs, die sonst keiner verwenden kann.
Okay, Leute, also, wir machen an der Stelle weiter, wo wir gestern aufgehört haben.
Ich würde das noch ein bisschen die Ärzte laufen lassen.
Allein schon, weil die Ärzte jetzt auf Spotify oder Amazon Music sind, was ja irgendwie gefühlt nur 20 Jahre gedauert hat.
Ich habe da aber wahrscheinlich auch ein paar nicht so ganz jugendfreie Sachen dabei.
Von ganz früher.
Wer weiß, es ist gleich der Bann auf Twitch raus.
Okay, wo sind wir gestern stehen geblieben?
Ich wollte noch vorhin irgendwas sagen.
Was wollte ich denn sagen noch?
Irgendwas wollte ich...
Achso, wir müssen heute Windows installieren.
Das wird ganz schlimm.
Windows in der VM.
Weil wir müssen ja testen, ob die Aktivierung funktioniert.
Eigentlich können wir die Windows installen, können wir doch eigentlich schon mal anwerfen, bevor wir irgendwas anderes machen.
Da kann das im Hintergrund schon mal installieren.
Ich habe mir auch irgendwo hier einen ISO hingeschmissen.
Wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wo, wäre auch schon mal ganz gut.
Wo habe ich mir denn das Windows-ISO hingeschmissen?
Da, da ist das Windows-ISO.
Windows 10, 809, Oktober, German.
Von Chip, 0.
Heute, naja, warum auch immer man ISOs von Chip runterlädt.
Ich poste den ganzen Kram jetzt nochmal auf Twitter kurz.
Dann schreibe ich mal, wie ihr macht.
Falls übrigens einer einen guten Stream-Titel, Idee hat, haut raus.
Ich bin ja bei sowas immer.
Ultra unkreativ.
Baba, Baba.
So, wir machen heute mit, ne, wir machen heute das Tool für im Stream fertig.
Mittlerweile fühlt sich das Tippen auf der Corsair-Tastatur echt gut an.
Ich habe ja eine ganze Weile gebraucht, mich dran zu gewöhnen, aber jetzt, jetzt ist es wirklich ganz nice für eine Gaming-Tastatur.
Ich finde die, ich finde die, die mechanische Tastatur, die ich auf der Arbeit geholt habe, extra, die ich also quasi nur zum Tippen geholt habe, finde ich noch einen Ticken angenehmer.
Ich habe das schon gefühlt 50 Mal gezeigt hier.
Die ist auch deutlich billiger.
Die ist, die ist rein vom Tipp-Gefühl her, ist die viel besser als, als die Corsair-Tastatur.
Aber mittlerweile geht es auch so.
Dafür hat man mehr Zusatzfunktionen auf dem Corsair-Ding.
Und zum Spielen ist sie besser.
Weil die Tasten irgendwie schneller sind.
Weiß auch nicht, kann man irgendwie schlecht beschreiben.
Wir machen heute das Tool für Hardware-Rad im Stream fertig.
So.
Corsair, ja, wie spricht man sich denn sonst aus?
Corsair, Corsair.
Wie spricht man, wir müssen jetzt gucken, wie man das ausspricht.
Corsair-Aussprache.
Also, ah, gucken wir mal.
Ah, jetzt mal.
Oh, das ist, das ist French.
Na, da wundert mich ja nichts mehr, ey.
Corsair.
Nee, ich glaube, ich glaube nicht, dass man das Corsair ausspricht.
Nee, das, ähm.
Oh nee, da wäre ich für gebannt.
Heutzutage darfst du dich nicht mal über dicke Lust nicht machen, selbst wenn du selbst dick bist.
Das, äh, ist nicht mal korrekt.
Auf Liebeslied habe ich jetzt auch keinen Bock.
Corsair.
Okay, Corsair.
Ja, ja, ich habe mich, ich habe mich jetzt damit abgefunden.
Hallo, Rolf.
Nee, nicht Rolf.
Roffel.
Hahaha, Rolf.
Er gerolft.
Corsair.
Ja, Corsair ist eher das hier.
So, also wir müssen jetzt mal Windows installieren, dass wir die Aktivierung, äh, testen können.
Ähm, deswegen.
Das lassen wir das mal im Hintergrund laufen, während das Ding installiert.
Äh.
Moment.
Wie legt man doch eine neue VM an?
So, hab ich eben immer gemacht.
Äh, Custom Workstation 10.
Und man muss auf eine Sache achten, bei, wenn man Windows 10 installiert.
Und zwar, ich muss mal gucken, wo man das auswählen kann.
Äh, äh, Windows, mach ich so selten.
Äh, und zwar muss man ihm sagen, wenn er die Festplatte anlegen will, ob das so geht, Moevi-Boot, mal gucken.
Äh, Prozessoren, aber zwei Cores, sonst zu lahm.
Äh, RAM haben wir genug.
Use Bridge Networking.
Man muss ihm sagen, an der Stelle, wo er sagt, ähm.
Latent New Disk.
Man muss ihm sagen, dass er alles in einem Single File storen soll.
Wenn er, wenn er das nicht macht, klappt das nicht.
Wolltest du nicht gestern Low Latency aktivieren?
Doch, wo, wo geht denn das?
Low Latency Video.
Aber so lang ist doch die Latency wirklich nicht, oder?
Lass mal Uhr, Uhrenvergleich.
Kann man den Scheiß hier irgendwie aufmachen noch?
Ja.
10, 11, 12, 13, 14.
Ich guck jetzt mal, wie weit ich bin hier.
Naja, komm, wir sind 18.
8 Sekunden, 8 Sekunden Unterschied.
Das ist nur wirklich nicht viel.
Die haben schon teilweise übelst bescheuerte Texte, Alter.
Ich wär gern Madonnas Dickdarm.
Und warum wäre er immer gerne Madonnas Dickdarm?
Weil dann wäre er immer satt.
Ist doch ganz klar.
So, wie geht denn das hier?
Ähm, wo steht denn, wie das geht?
To enable, simply go to your dashboard and select settings.
Okay.
Ich mach das jetzt mal.
Ich hoffe, das geht.
Ich hoffe, das geht im laufenden Betrieb.
Ah, ja.
Next time you start a broadcast.
Okay, Leute.
Ich mach das jetzt an.
Und das nächste Mal haben wir dann Low Latency Options.
Wo ist das?
Kommst du zurück am Ring?
Nein, das ist mir mittlerweile...
Also erstens sind es da mittlerweile nicht mehr so viele Bands, die mir gefallen.
Und zweitens ist das unglaublich teuer geworden, ey.
Das war das letzte Mal schon teuer, wo ich da war.
Und ey, ich weiß gar nicht, was mittlerweile der Eintritt kostet.
Okay, wo ist das denn jetzt hier?
Channel, from the select channel, under settings.
Okay.
Ich hab's natürlich auf deutsches Kanal.
There you will see an option to set your optimization preference.
Select low latency.
Ah, ja, hier.
Hier.
Geringe Latenz.
Am besten gar nicht für Interaktion mit Zuschauern in der nahezu Echtzeit.
Okay.
Ich hab das jetzt aktiviert, Leute.
Muss man nicht mehr speichern, ne?
Children of the night.
So, jetzt ist Low Latency am Start.
Nächstes Mal, wenn wir streben, anfangen.
So, machen wir mal Windows install...
Oh, fuck, hab ich auch noch Festplattenplatz?
110 MB... äh, 110 GB.
Das müsste reichen.
Wie viel Platz brauchen so eine Windows-Installation?
Für eine nackte Installation, mit der wir nichts machen, reichen doch 40 GB bestimmt auch aus, oder?
Ich finde das übrigens sehr nice.
Muss ich jetzt mal loswerden, so an euch.
Wie viele Leute, und ich sehe ja auch im Chat, es sind oftmals einfach auch die gleichen,
wie viele Leute hier immer am Start sind.
Gerade bei den Nicht-Gaming-Streams.
Finde ich sehr nice.
Okay, meinst du, 40 GB reichen nicht?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Bla, bla, bla.
Bridged Automatic.
Gucken wir mal, bridged überhaupt funktioniert hier von dem Account aus.
Was macht er da?
Ich installiere mir Windows in der VM.
Das ist ja nicht so einfach.
Ich will mal sehen, dass ich mein Aktivierungstool testen kann.
Also, nein, wir aktivieren mit keinen illegalen Keys.
Darf ich dazu sagen.
Ich will gucken, ob die Aktivierung fehlschlägt und der Key dann nicht gelöscht wird.
Das können wir nämlich testen.
Wirklich die Aktivierung testen kann natürlich dann Airplus selber.
So.
Gucken wir mal.
Install, ISO.
Wo habe ich das komische ISO, oder?
Äh.
ISO.
Okay, auf geht's.
Wir schmeißen jetzt schon mal die Windows-Installation an.
Und dann können wir nachher, können wir dann gleich weiter basteln.
Alter, eine Windows-Installation.
Ich fasse es nicht.
Ich glaube, so ist das ganz gut für die Windows-Installation.
Das lassen wir jetzt.
Ja, ja, wir sind fertig installieren.
Okay, IP ist schon mal 210.
Oh, oh, wir haben, wir haben den Key nicht gepresst.
Ganz, ganz schlimm bei Microsoft.
Wenn man den Key nicht presst, ist Instant Loss.
Auf, mach hin.
Windows 10, please.
Oh, Key.
So, Key gepresst.
Das ist ja mehr Intens als Battlefield.
Eine Windows-VM, eine, ja, Windows in der Windows-VM ist schon geil, ne?
Installationssprache.
Kannst du die auf Englisch stellen?
Na, meinetwegen, das war alles auf Deutsch.
Weiter.
Jetzt installieren.
Windows-Installation.
Wo ist die Mac-VM?
Habe ich nicht hier.
Geht aber mittlerweile.
Zwar nur mit einem inoffiziellen, aber auch mit einem inoffiziellen, aber auch mit einem inoffiziellen, aber auch mit einem inoffiziellen.
Vmware-Patch.
Ah, Microsoft war sich zu schade, den Mauszeiger anzupassen im Textfeld, im Installer.
Das ist natürlich auch viel zu komplex.
Ich habe keinen.
Produkt-Key.
Und wir wollen installieren.
Was installieren wir?
Wir installieren Windows Pro.
Das ist eigentlich der Unterschied.
Ich glaube, hier ist kein Bitlocker dabei, ne?
Kennst du hier mal mit den unterschiedlichen Windows-Versionen aus?
Ich glaube, der größte Unterschied zwischen Home und Pro ist, dass in Pro-Bitlocker, da ist kein Bitlocker dabei.
Da ist kein Bitlocker dabei.
Da ist kein Bitlocker dabei, also in der Home nicht, ne?
Oder?
Fenster verschieben geht auch nicht.
Übrigens, fällt euch mal auf, dass der Windows-10-Installer sich optisch überhaupt nicht mehr deckt mit der Optik von Windows-10.
Die sieht total anders aus.
Fail.
Was, Moment.
In Pro kann man Remote Desktop machen.
Heißt das etwa, dass man in einer nicht...
Pro-Windows-Version allen Ernstes keinen Remote Desktop machen kann?
Was ist mit Microsoft los, ey?
Sind die doch ganz bei Sinn, oder?
Nicht zugewiesen.
Hoffentlich reicht der Speicherplatz.
Ha!
Oho, hat gerade so gereicht.
Okay, Windows, mach dein Ding.
Wir programmieren jetzt weiter.
Ich guck da, mal gucken ungefähr, wie schnell das geht.
Na, das geht doch eigentlich.
Ich meine, man darf hier auch nicht vergessen,
es ist von SSD-Auto.
Auf SSD in einer VM.
Also, das muss eigentlich schneller gehen, als auf dem Rechner selbst.
Ach so, man kann sich nur auf dem Windows-Pro per Remote Desktop verbinden.
Das ist auch schon wieder total beknackt, ne?
Dass es überhaupt diese Beschränkung wieder gibt beim Microsoft.
Bitte im Audit-Modus testen mit der Aktivierung.
Was ist der Audit-Modus?
Welche Ärzteplatte läuft da?
Das ist Random-Playlist.
Das ist hier Random-Ärzte-Playlist von mir.
Also, das ist jetzt Dings hier, Planet Punk.
Oder, nicht Planet Punk, Planet Punk.
Guck mal, das geht doch richtig schnell, Windows-Installation.
Ctrl-Shift-F3 drücken, wenn er nach der Sprache fragt.
Was macht denn der Audit-Modus?
Ich habe keinen Schimmer von Windows.
Außer, dass ich Windows benutze.
Ist die Musik-Lautstärke eigentlich in Ordnung so?
Ich habe es jetzt mal nicht so laut gemacht wie sonst,
weil ich weiß nicht, ob die Ärzte unbedingt jedermanns Fall sind hier.
Guck mal, easy, Windows-Installation fertig.
Krass, ging ja mega schnell.
Kannst du Programme installieren ohne einen Benutzer?
Ich will doch Benutzer anlegen.
Ich will einen Benutzer anlegen und gucken, ob der richtig übertragen wird.
Wow, was ist das da unten?
Wir machen mal kurz groß.
So.
Full-Screen-Windows-VM.
Das ist jetzt Windows-Seption-Extreme.
Vor allem, da ist jetzt das Oktober-Update schon dabei.
So macht man das aber bei Hardware mit der Installation-Aktivierung.
Das ist natürlich eine Sache.
Wenn das so ist, muss man das so ausprobieren.
Sag mir mal, wann ich das klicken muss.
Was sagst du?
Ctrl-Shift-F3, wenn er nach der Sprache fragt.
Okay.
Wann fragt er denn nach der Sprache?
Oder war das schon?
Muss ich das Ganze jetzt nochmal machen.
Oktober-Update-RTX-On.
Poggers-RTX.
Also ich muss jetzt mal...
Ich habe es ja auf Twitter schon geschrieben, Nvidia-Grafiker.
Also.
Wenn ich mir überlege, dass eine RTX 208 Ti ungefähr das Doppelte kostet.
Sagen wir mal, drei Viertel bis das Doppelte.
Also ich kann nicht rechnen, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Also so 80 bis 100% mehr.
Als eine 1080 Ti.
Muss ich sagen.
Der Leistungssprung um 30% ist, finde ich, nicht gerechtfertigt bei einem fast doppelt so hohen Preis.
Und ich meine mal ganz ehrlich.
RTX-On.
Ist dir nichts besseres eingefallen?
Kennt ihr dieses komische Video von Nvidia da?
RTX-On, wartet mal.
Während Windows im Hintergrund sein Zeug rumspackt.
Ich meine...
Warte mal, warte mal.
Wenn sie das Auto explodieren lassen.
Das ist...
Warte mal.
Wo lassen sie das Auto explodieren?
Hier.
Guck mal.
Also.
Hier zeigen sie uns...
Okay.
Hier ist ein Auto und hinter dem Auto explodiert jetzt gleich was.
Aber ja.
So.
Jetzt machen sie gleich die komische Explosion.
Übrigens, sie sind super...
Super amazed hier im Hintergrund.
Achtung.
Das müsst ihr euch jetzt mal anhören.
Lass mal Bela mal kurz muten.
Passt mal auf.
Passt mal auf, ja.
Wie sie ausflippen.
Well.
So, of course, one of the big challenges of SSR is also complex surfaces like this.
Ultra-complex surface.
If we set off an explosion behind the tank here, but next to the car.
Oh, come on.
Oh.
Actually within the car.
Also, man muss sagen.
Hey.
Um es mal gar nicht schlecht zu reden.
Reflektionen realistischer zu machen ist schon ganz nice.
Ja.
Aber.
Ich meine, das sieht schon cool aus, ja.
Wie performant das läuft für was anderes.
Aber die Sache ist ja nun mal die.
Es ist für mich absolut unverständlich, warum man das nicht auch so machen kann.
Also.
Ich meine, eine Explosion spiegeln lassen auf einer Oberfläche.
Ich meine, warum geht das nur mit Raytracing?
Das erschließt sich mir aus der Sache überhaupt nicht.
Wenn man das programmiert in seinem Spiel.
Dann geht das selbstverständlich auch ohne Raytracing.
Das hat doch damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Das ist unmöglich.
Wie würdest du das mit dem RTX-R sehen?
Fake hype intensifies.
Wie sieht das hier aus?
Also, lass uns.
Ja.
Wow, das sieht unglaublich aus.
Und natürlich wird es dynamisch aufgebaut.
Alles.
Reflektionen werden niemals das gleiche sein.
Schau dir die Reflektionen auf dem Boden an, Leute.
Es ist nur.
Ja.
Also, du kannst sehen.
Wow, es passiert einfach.
Es ist unangenehm.
Also, du kannst sehen.
Wow, es passiert einfach.
Wenn es mit dem SSR im Screen Space ist, dann erhältst du noch einige Reflektionen auf
dem Auto, aber wegen der Natur des SSR, verschwindet es, wenn er weggeht.
Naja, ich wollte es einfach mal so anzeigen.
Also.
Hallo.
Ich bin Kot.
Ich habe etwas WLAN da und schon ist dein PC betriebsklar.
Verwende deine Stimme oder die Tastatur.
Wenn ich still sein soll, wähle einfach das kleine Mikrofonsymbol am unteren Bildschirm
Wir drücken jetzt Strg und Eingabe, kann man Cortana nicht sagen, dass Cortana ruhig sein
soll?
Das müssen wir jetzt mal gucken.
Ja, Cortana, lass uns loslegen, auf geht's.
Ah, und was muss ich jetzt drücken?
Strg, Alt und F3 hast du gesagt, nee, was muss ich drücken?
Warte mal, ich scroll nochmal hoch, äh, Strg, Shift, F3, Strg, Shift, F3, wow, da passiert
was, es rebootet, ah nee, es bewegt sich noch, machen wir mal wieder Musik an, ist Cortana
vielleicht ruhig?
Na, ähm, ich muss halt irgendwie Sachen draufkopieren können, weil ich hab halt nix im Installer
drin, ne, im Gegensatz zu euch, Administrator, einen Moment bitte, aber es ist gut zu wissen,
dass wenn man das drückt, dass man sich nicht durch diesen ganzen Cortana-Miss durchklicken
muss, weil das geht jetzt, das wäre jetzt gefühlt 10 Minuten gegangen.
Hallo, was wird heute gemacht, es wird, äh, mach mal Ausrufezeichen HR-Tool.
Dann, es kommt die Erklärung, wat, was war das daneben, jetzt ist es weg, was tut es denn?
Ja, ok, ähm, muss ich jetzt irgendwas machen?
Ok, wir installieren jetzt erstmal VMware Tools, erstmal, nee, erstmal Leute, erstmal
mal ein Snapshot, man weiß nie, was dir passiert, wir installieren erstmal VMware Tools, dass
ich Zeug draufkopieren kann, 800 mal 600, ich glaube, wir können jetzt auch schon höher
einstellen.
Ne, warte mal, wo geht, wo, wo geht denn das nochmal, Anzeigeeinstellung, ah, das ist wieder
so eklig, ah, VMware Tools, jaja, installieren wir mal, sollen wir mal gucken, ob Netzwerk
funktioniert?
Alter, die Windows in der VM ruckelt, das ist aber, äh, läuft mit Manjaro aber besser.
Ok, wow, ok, Netzwerk geht, fertig, nice.
Nein, wir wollen nicht.
Nein, wir wollen nicht neu starten.
Guck mal, jetzt läuft es auch hier wieder relativ schnell.
Ah, ist das das neue Windows, das Oktober Windows, äh, Update?
Das gucken wir uns mal in einem eigenen Stream an, was es da Neues gibt.
Hier wird jetzt erstmal der ganze Mist von Microsoft nachgeladen.
Systemvorbereitung kann ich zumachen, ok, gut, ähm, machen wir nochmal einen Snapshot,
Snapshot hier mit VMware Tools, einen alten löschen wir wieder.
Und dann können wir nämlich mal ausbrennen, ob das funktioniert.
Ok.
Dann können wir nämlich mal ausbrennen, ob der Kram funktioniert.
Ne, das ist das falsche Git, das ist, das, das aktuelle Tool ist nicht, ist noch nicht
im Git.
Ok, nice.
Gut, wir sagen, programmieren wir mal weiter.
Also, wir sind gestern stehen geblieben, schauen wir uns das Ganze nochmal an.
Relativ, oh, Moment, wir haben das falsche Projekt aktiviert.
Wir müssen nicht Kogas starten, wir müssen Proggas starten.
Was, Kogas?
Proggas?
Proggas müssen wir starten.
Proggas ist das Webinterface.
Ok.
Wir sind hier relativ billig gestartet, wir machen die Seite jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
hübscher.
Ähm, wir machen eine eigene, wir machen noch eine eigene CSS-Seite, dass das ein bisschen
was hermacht.
CSS, wo ist es, da, Styles, so, und dann kopieren wir jetzt den ganzen Krempel von hier rüber,
weg.
Ok.
Damit, zack, der Image sonst was, bla, wow, achso, ich habe das ja noch gar nicht hinzugefügt,
lol.
Link, Styles, so, gut, wir machen jetzt ein paar, paar Basic, paar Basic Styles da rein,
dass das nicht mehr ganz so hässlich aussieht.
Also, wir kopieren uns, wir kopieren uns jetzt mal aus dem Meme-Tool.
Mal das, ähm.
Farbschema, weil das sieht, also das Light-Farbschema, weil das sieht eigentlich ganz hübsch aus.
Es ist doch schon, ja, da.
So, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, ähm, warum ist denn das so groß hier?
Ah, weg damit.
Ne, wir lassen das mal als Light-Theme.
In dem Fall, das kommt ja dann nicht so sehr auf die Optik an.
Wie nennen wir das überhaupt?
Ach, egal, wie wir es nennen.
Wir müssen bloß Body, die passende Klasse geben.
Ok, passt.
So, und dann sagen wir jetzt mal einen Button, machen wir den Button schön.
Button, Border 0, Border Radius, wir machen, wir machen ein bisschen, ein bisschen gebogen.
Die Höhe machen wir irgendwie 30 Pixel und Background-Color und jetzt kommt CSS-Variable,
das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Wusste ich vorher auch nicht, dass es das gibt.
Bevor ich mich hier in letzter Zeit mal ein bisschen mehr mit CSS-Kram beschäftigt habe,
hier kann man jetzt sagen, ne, warte mal, war, und hier kann man jetzt sagen, was man
machen will, zum Beispiel irgendwie orange oder so.
Und wenn man jetzt refresht, ist der Knopf ordentlich gestylt und orange.
Das finde ich sehr, sehr nice.
So, Solution Explorer, kann man den hier irgendwie anhängen?
So, wir kopieren uns jetzt die Index-Seite ein paar mal.
So, wir legen, wir kopieren uns jetzt die Index-Seite ein paar mal und so.
Und zwar, ne, vorher machen wir nochmal was anderes.
Kann ich das nicht löschen?
Kann ich das nur löschen, wenn ich das stoppe?
So, ähm, das ist ein orangener Knopf, richtig.
Was er macht, ist erstmal egal, Hauptsache er ist orange.
Ähm, ist der Proggers ein APS, ja, ja, ja, das ist ASP.NET Core.
Das Core ist wichtig.
So, also, das, das wird unser Navigationsmenü, das muss man jetzt ein bisschen schön machen.
Hier geht man auf Index, hier geht man auf, ähm, Logs, und hier geht man auf, das können
wir nachher noch als Razor Views machen, dass es da ein bisschen, bisschen drum herum gespart
ist, aber ich kopiere mir jetzt einfach mal das HTML.
So, und dann brauchen wir noch Stats.
So, von der Idee her, hier sind die Keys drinne.
Ja.
Hier ist die History drinne, also sprich, äh, welche Keys benutzt sind und wann, und hier
gibt's, keine Ahnung, hier machen wir ein paar hübsche Graphen, da können wir uns
ein bisschen austoben.
So, Class, ähm, haben wir irgendwelche, ja, Tab, Class, oh, es gibt jetzt, Leute, ich
hab jetzt gesehen, es gibt jetzt in Visual Studio, passt mal auf, es gibt irgendwie,
wie ging, wie ging das, ähm, Alt, Control, guck mal, man kann jetzt Multiple Cursor machen
in, in Visual Studio, ist jetzt neu.
Ah, schon ist's kaputt, bam, lull, schon ist's kaputt, aber ist trotzdem ganz nice,
oder?
So, und da machen wir jetzt irgendwie sowas wie, äh, Tab, dass es ein bisschen hübscher
aussieht, die Navigationsbuttons, die wir hier oben haben, starten wir mal, so, Tab, die
Dinger kriegen jetzt mal, ähm, erstes Mal kriegen die ein bisschen Platz drumherum,
oh, da war's Padding.
Ich kann das immer nicht merken.
Oh, da war's Padding.
Also, beim
hübschen Padding und, ich gucke mir das, ja, also ich denke mir das gerade nicht aus,
guck mir das vom, Vom妳 Board ab, ah, sieht schon ein bisschen besser aus, Color, Var,
ah, das ist keine gute Farbe dafür, oder?
So, was können wir denn hier, machen wir mal Weiß, äh, Schwarz.
Ja.
Wird ein weißer Knopf angezeigt, schon wird 0, 0, 0, wird zu weiß.
So, da haben wir noch mal ein Projekt drin.
Oben drüber.
Was ist Padding, Padding?
Margin ist außenrum, okay.
Das heißt, dann haben wir nach oben mehr Platz.
Nee.
Dann haben wir nach oben nicht mehr Platz.
Ich meine, wir können da einfach ein Projekt dazwischen machen.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin nicht so der HTML-Java-Skript-Held.
So, so ist auch okay.
So, und dann machen wir noch was.
Terafox, heute ist alles rassistisch im Zweifelsfall.
Das muss ja der Falsche hören.
Guck mal, wie das blau aussieht.
Meine Links sind blau, das ist eigentlich ganz nett.
So, und jetzt machen wir...
Ach so, geht überhaupt nicht.
Falsches Blau.
Oh, sieht eigentlich ganz nett aus.
So, und jetzt machen wir...
Trick 17.
Das Tab, was active ist,
kriegt unten drunter...
kriegt unten drunter einen Rahmen.
Gucken, wie das so aussieht.
Lass mal sehen, auf welcher Seite...
Der sieht scheiße aus.
Das machen wir hier irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Design, damit habe ich es ja...
Ja, ja, okay.
Das reicht jetzt.
Das war okay so, oder?
Wieso benutzt du den Bootstrap?
Weil...
Keine Ahnung.
Weil wir das selbst machen.
Ich weiß nicht, so sieht das doch ganz okay aus.
Machen wir das mal umgedreht.
Wie sieht das hier mit Blue aus?
Oh, das ist doch hübsch.
Das ist doch ganz hübsch.
Finde ich eigentlich ganz gut so.
Ticken schmaler oder...
Keine Ahnung, wir lassen es jetzt erstmal so.
So, Tab.
Gut, dann können wir jetzt nämlich den Index ein paar Mal kopieren.
Und zwar brauchen wir jetzt noch...
Müssen wir das umbenennen.
Rename.
Ach, das geht ja wieder nicht, wenn es läuft.
Stats.
Und Rename Logs.
Sollten es die Seiten zumindest schon geben.
Ja, nice.
Gut.
Logs.
Stats.
Falsch.
Wenn ich es jetzt so richtig machen würde...
Dann wird es auch funktionieren.
So, okay.
Jetzt haben wir sowas wie eine Navigationsleiste.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Das muss jetzt erstmal reichen.
So, und jetzt müssen wir das ein bisschen interaktiver machen.
Und zwar will ich, dass...
Dass das hier disabled ist.
Also das Textfeld...
Soll...
Soll disabled sein.
Äh, read only.
Read only und disabled.
Nee, muss man...
Ach, da muss man irgendwas reinschreiben, ne?
Da muss man reinschreiben.
Disabled.
Disabled, disabled.
Das ist auch so eine Ausgeburt von HTML, wo man sich wieder denkt...
The fuck?
Ähm...
Äh...
Ah, ja.
Wenn man das jetzt noch im richtigen...
Im richtigen macht, weil man alles nicht kopiert hat, dann klappt das auch.
Okay, nice.
So, und ich will es jetzt so machen, wenn ich hier auf edit klicke, dann wird es editierbar.
Und dann können wir posten.
Nur disabled oder read only, das können wir mal gleich ausprobieren.
Ich lösche die Logs und Stats-Seiten nochmal.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal die Index-Seite fertig.
Wir müssen noch view einbinden.
Habe ich gerade Index gelöscht?
Ist das jetzt im Papierkorb?
Index.
15, 16, ja.
Da ist es wieder.
Fockers!
Hahaha.
Ähm...
Moment.
Falsches...
Projekt.
Hier ist es wieder.
Logs weg, Stats weg.
So, und jetzt machen wir da mal...
Kommt...
Kommt noch view rein.
Script.
So, und das kopieren wir uns jetzt.
Das kopiere ich mir aus dem...
Aus dem Memeboard raus.
Eigentlich ganz einfach.
Ähm...
Weil wir müssen es ja ein bisschen interaktiver machen, ne?
Das musst du ja ab und zu mal refreshen, ob es neue Keys gibt und sowas.
Ähm...
Jetzt können wir es so lassen.
Das passt.
Ich habe da schon was vorbereitet.
Mounted.
Genau.
Also von der Idee her müssen wir jetzt...
Index gelöscht.
Ja, jetzt ist es schon verkackt.
So, ähm...
Moment.
Das ergibt ja überhaupt keinen Sinn, was ich hier mache.
Wir müssen erst mal...
...einen Diff reinhauen, was App heißt.
Weil view sucht das Ganze.
Und da kommt der ganze andere Schmodder rein.
Genau, so.
Bla bla bla bla.
Keys, Auto-Update.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob es funktioniert.
Oder ob es eine Fehlermeldung schmeißt.
What?
Das habe ich falsch gemacht.
Äh, wo ist hier zu viel?
Irgendwo ist ein Komma zu viel.
Wo ist das Problem hier?
Ah!
Okay, wunderbar.
Funktioniert.
Ähm...
So, jetzt brauchen wir...
Mounted.
Das ist das, was view ausführt, wenn es geladen wird.
Und da müssen wir jetzt Keys abrufen.
Und nachdem wir diesmal kein Signal R oder sonst was am Start haben...
Ähm...
Machen wir jetzt die ganz billige JavaScript-Variante.
Wir rufen einfach einmal in der Sekunde alle unverbrauchten Keys ab.
Das heißt, dazu brauchen wir noch eine Methode, die...
Wenn wir irgendwie...
Get Keys.
So, und in Get Keys...
Machen wir einen Fetch von der Idee her.
Machen wir einen Fetch.
Und, ähm...
Rufen von...
Wie habe ich es hier genannt?
Key Controller.
Rufen von hier alle Keys ab.
Äh, was?
Gab es mal eine Zeit, in der du hauptberuflich YouTube gemacht hast?
Nein.
Oder mehr verdient hast als in deinem eigenen Job.
Also, als ich mal wirklich richtig viel gemacht habe...
Und, ähm...
Auch, auch Sellout, G2A...
Elgato, Nvidia, alles gemacht habe.
Da habe ich ungefähr so viel verdient mit YouTube wie in meinem anderen Job.
Aber, mittlerweile verdiene ich in meinem anderen Job im Tinken mehr als früher.
Und mit YouTube viel weniger, weil ich nichts mache.
Selbstschuld.
Ja.
Das ist ein eindeutiger Fall von Selbstschuld.
So, wir gucken jetzt mal in die Datenbank, ob wir da noch was drinstehen hatten von gestern.
Nope, keine Keys.
Müssen wir gleich noch einfügen.
Aber von der Idee her.
Wir machen jetzt ein...
Wir machen das Async.
Ähm...
Wir haben schon Datenfelder für Keys und für Edit und Auto-Update.
Gut, dass ich das vorher schon mal ausprobiert habe.
Ähm...
So, jetzt müssen wir die ganzen Keys, die es noch gibt, vom Server abrufen.
Wieso hast du die Lust an YouTube verloren?
Ich habe gar nicht so wirklich die Lust an YouTube verloren.
Ähm...
Mir geht YouTube als Plattform übelst auf den Sack.
Dementsprechend will ich mich da eigentlich gar nicht mehr großartig aufhalten.
Gerade...
Ähm...
Wobei es wieder besser wird.
Weil ich einfach komplett YouTube Deutschland ignoriere.
So, wir müssen jetzt mal einen Fetch.
Einen Fetch.
Await.
Await Fetch.
So, und jetzt müssen wir quasi fetchen.
Von Slash RP.
Slash Keys.
Das ist das, was wir hier...
Da.
Ein bisschen erklären, was ich so treibe.
Was wir hier abrufen.
Ja, das ist der...
Das ist der RP Keys Controller.
Und, ähm...
Ohne Argumente hintendran ruft er das Get auf.
Oh, RP Fetch, RP Keys.
Und jetzt muss man sagen...
Wir brauchen noch ein paar Sachen.
Wir müssen nämlich noch angeben.
Method.
Get.
Wobei, müssen wir gar nicht angeben, oder?
Ich glaube, Get macht er standardmäßig.
Dann lassen wir es mal weg.
Okay, ähm...
Response.
Will ich...
Das machen wir jetzt in dem Else-Zweig.
Dann will ich sagen, ich möchte editieren.
Wenn ich die Form editieren kann,
dann möchte ich safen und zum Server schicken.
So, und ich habe jetzt gelesen, man kann...
Also, mit, mit, äh...
So, so klassischem...
So, jQuery würde ich jetzt hier irgendwie sagen...
Keine Ahnung, gib mir die Form.
Oder, oder, äh...
Document.
Get Element.
By ID.
Irgendwie Form.
So.
Das ist natürlich nicht im Sinne von...
Von Vue.js, weil das zu, äh...
Zu herkömmliches JavaScript ist oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Deswegen habe ich letztens gelesen, man kann das auch so machen.
Guck.
Man sagt hier ref oder refs.
Refs war es.
Refs.
Und da gibt man jetzt hier Name ein.
Irgendwie Form.
Und jetzt kann man quasi direkt drauf zugreifen aus Vue.
Ich muss erstmal...
Ich muss mal nachgucken, wie das funktioniert hat.
Ref.
Haben wir jetzt...
Vielleicht noch irgendwie mal ein ordentliches Beispiel.
X, Single F.
Ja, genau.
So ging das.
Jetzt kann ich auf Form.
Und dann Submit.
Direkt von der Form.
So.
Und jetzt sollte das eigentlich funktionieren.
Ah.
Das ist doch refs.
Ref.
Doch nur ref.
Nice.
Funktioniert.
Du hast es gesehen?
Ich klicke jetzt rein.
Darf ich editieren?
Und wenn man dann...
Ähm...
Saved.
Und jetzt...
Jetzt wenn man quasi aus dem Edit wieder rausgeht, dann saved er.
Oder auch nicht?
Doch, macht er.
Nice.
Guck.
Hat er gespeichert.
Das ist ganz cool.
So.
Von der Idee her müsste es jetzt eigentlich passen.
Habe ich die jetzt...
Jetzt gucken wir mal im SQLite Browser, ob da Kram auf dem Server angekommen ist.
Ja.
Da sind die ganzen Keys drin.
Die ganzen Fakes.
Auch mit richtigem Datum und alles.
So.
Und jetzt machen wir nochmal was ekliges.
Und zwar, weil wir hier keine Informationen haben, wann denn neue Keys...
Oder wir kriegen keine Informationen vom Server, wenn sich was geändert hat.
Oder wenn jemand in einem anderen Browser Keys submittet oder so.
Wir werden einfach jetzt das ganz billig machen.
Wenn ihr da eine schönere Idee habt, außer dass wir jetzt halt wieder SignalR oder irgendwas für Echtzeitkommunikation da verwenden.
Dann...
Ähm...
Wir machen jetzt einfach eine Schleife, in der wir alle Sekunde abfragen, ob es neue Keys gibt.
Jede Sekunde neue Keys abrufen.
Fertig.
Funktioniert das jetzt?
Ja.
Er ruft jetzt jede Sekunde.
Wie lange streamst du heute?
Ich würde sagen, bis das fertig ist.
Oder bis das zumindest in der Form ist, dass sie das mal ausprobieren können.
Weil morgen ist Montag.
Da sind sie ja wahrscheinlich wieder am schaffen.
Da können sie es ja mal ausprobieren.
Ob das so funktioniert, wie wir uns das gedacht haben.
So.
Er ruft jetzt die Keys ab.
Jetzt müssen wir die Keys noch in das Textfeld reinschreiben.
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Get Keys.
So.
Hier haben wir die ganzen Keys drinne.
Das heißt, unser Textfeld...
Unser Textfeld kriegt als Model, also sprich, da wo es die Daten drin schreibt, das Keysfeld...
Ich meine, da ist aktuell noch nichts drin.
Ob es funktioniert, können wir einfach mal so testen, wenn wir hier was reinschreiben.
Ja. Funktioniert.
So. Und jetzt müssen wir die Keys hier reinschreiben.
Und zwar jedes Mal...
Jedes Mal, wenn wir Keys bekommen, müssen wir uns da jetzt die richtigen Keys rausfiltern.
Weil, das Problem ist ja...
Ich zeige es hier nochmal.
Das sind ja nicht nur Keys.
Das sind ja...
Das sind ja komplett alle Informationen, die wir haben.
Also sprich, wann es erstellt wurde.
Äh...
Wann es benutzt wurde und sowas.
Das brauchen wir an der Stelle gar nicht.
Wir brauchen eigentlich jetzt nur...
Die Keys aus diesem Array.
Kann man... Kann man sowas machen?
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Ähm...
Map.
Und dann sagen wir irgendwie Item.
Item.
Und daraus wollen wir jetzt den Key.
Und den schreiben wir in Keys.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, das wird so nicht funktionieren.
Weil JavaScript der Meinung ist, das geht mit...
Not...
Not used.
Remove range.
Unused license.
So, jetzt können wir nämlich mal ein bisschen...
Bisschen löschen.
Da sieht man aber auch schon, das Ding lädt auch noch halbwegs schnell mit 6.000 Lizenzen
drin.
Ich glaube, 6.000 Lizenzen werden sie da nicht drin haben.
Löschen.
Oh, es ist abgekackt.
Warum ist es abgekackt?
Aber...
Funktioniert natürlich immer noch.
Wie viele Keys sind das jetzt?
Kann man das nicht reinpasten?
Ich darf das nicht kopieren.
Warum darf ich das nicht kopieren?
Ist das zu viel oder was?
Darf ich so viel nicht copy-pasten?
Ah, 3000.
Okay.
So viel werden sie ja nie drin haben,
unused Keys.
So, dann löschen wir den Krempel mal.
Oh, zack.
Alle weg.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Wir machen jetzt noch was.
Wir sagen, wir wollen bloß noch
die Keys haben.
Ah, wir machen das jetzt mal richtig schön.
Wir wollen jetzt nur noch die Keys haben,
die
Einzel sind.
Wir hatten doch letztens mal das Thema,
wie man aus einer Liste
doppelte Einträge löschen kann.
So, ganz einfach.
Hier wirft er alle doppelten
Einträge raus.
So.
Also, von der Idee her,
was uns jetzt natürlich passieren kann, ist,
also sprich, wenn ich nichts
pushe, ist gut, dann will ich alles
unusede löschen.
Das ergibt irgendwie Sinn.
Allerdings,
ich will nicht,
alles doppelt und dreifach
einfügen.
Gucken, was jetzt passiert, wenn ich jetzt die gleichen
Keys einfüge.
Ja, da speichert es noch doppelt und dreifach.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Warum speichert es
noch doppelt und dreifach?
Ähm,
weil,
ja klar, weil
er sich immer nur die gepushten anguckt,
die Keys, die er pusht, und nicht
die, die er schon in der Datenbank drin hat.
Das heißt, wir machen,
das ist mir ein bisschen zu lang hier, ich hab ne Idee, was wir machen.
Das müsste eigentlich ganz gut funktionieren.
Wir speichern uns das hier mal als
Unique Keys, wobei,
das ist nicht Keys, das stimmt ja nicht.
Das sind ja
Licenses. Sollten wir das auch ordentlich benennen.
Rename.
Das mag ich auch in Visual Studio,
dass das so einfach geht.
Unique Licenses, zack.
Moment.
Das hab ich doppelt benannt.
Na geil.
Und in dem Fall,
in dem Fall ist das,
ist das weder noch, was mach ich denn eigentlich
für ein Blödsinn? In dem Fall ist es gar nichts,
in dem Fall ist es der Input,
der Input, den ich gepusht kriege.
Das heißt, wir sind noch nicht mal klar,
ob es Licenses oder Keys sind.
Nennen wir es mal Input.
Sind einfach Lines.
Unique Lines
sind's. Das trifft's
eigentlich am ehesten.
So, und hier ist es nicht
Key.
Hier ist es Line.
Oh ne, Kinder.
Gibt nichts Nervigeres als Kinder.
Du hast Unused in der Variable falsch geschrieben.
Echt?
Ah, Unsued.
Er wurde noch nicht verklagt. Anzeige ist raus, ja.
So, Unique Lines, bla bla bla.
So, und jetzt von der Theorie her.
Jetzt guck ich hier nicht nur,
ob er Regex matcht, sondern
ich schaue, ob das,
was ich quasi einfügen will,
nicht schon hier drinnen ist.
Ähm, da können wir einfach sagen,
Unused Licenses Any.
Und dann gucken wir
License
Key gleich,
wenn es nicht
da drin ist. Wenn es nicht da drin ist
und der Regex matcht,
dann wollen wir es hinzufügen. Also von der Idee her,
ich weiß nicht, ob es funktioniert. Müssen wir gleich mal gucken.
Also von der Idee her würde ich sagen,
der splittet hier
die gepushten Lizenzkeys.
Also rein der Text.
Macht eine Schleife drüber.
Dann guckt er, ob, ähm,
ein Key, den
ich hinzufügen will, nicht zufällig
schon drinnen ist.
Dann wollen wir ihn nicht
wieder hinzufügen.
Ja. Das müsste
eigentlich funktionieren.
So, probieren wir das mal aus.
Oh ne, ich brauch wieder ein Windows Key.
Ich brauch Windows Key
as a Service, ja.
Okay, das sollte nicht funktionieren.
Also den sollte er
jetzt rausschmeißen, oder? Von der Idee her.
Ja, wunderbar. Sehr schön.
Ah.
Big Brain.
Guck, und er speichert jetzt den Mist auch nicht mehr.
Also sprich, wenn ich, selbst wenn ich den Cards
jetzt doppelt hier reinpaste,
speichert er jeweils nur noch einen.
So muss das sein.
Jetzt ist die Frage, können wir schon was Lauses löschen?
Ich glaub, das geht nicht.
Es ist eigentlich ein Fall, der kommt nicht vor, ne?
Eigentlich sollte man das nicht löschen können.
Aber es könnte ja sein, dass
ähm, dass die Jungs jetzt sagen,
hey, wir haben diesen Key hier von Hand
genommen und aktiviert, wir müssen ihn entfernen.
Könnte ja immer noch sein.
Und das funktioniert nämlich schon nicht.
So. Das heißt, wenn wir
hier durch sind, müssen wir
abschließend noch gucken, ob es Keys gibt,
die jetzt quasi unbenutzt sind.
Also nennen wir's
mal Removed
Removed Licenses.
Und da muss ich mir jetzt mal ein bisschen den
den Kopf zerbiegen.
Zerbrechen.
Wie auch immer.
Wie wir das am besten rauskriegen.
Wirst du dafür eigentlich bezahlt oder machst du das for free?
Äh, ich mach das komplett umsonst.
Hauptsächlich aus dem Grund,
dass ich streamen kann.
Und das ist ein relativ überschaubares
Projekt.
Außerdem finde ich's geil, was er mit seinem Shop macht.
Die meisten Leute, ne?
Deswegen finde ich das bei ihm auch cool.
Die meisten Leute labert immer nur rum.
So nach dem Motto, oh, wir müssen hier irgendwas machen.
Und am schlimmsten
sind dann die Leute, die sich drüber beschweren.
So nach dem Motto, irgendjemand anderes hat was gemacht
und es funktioniert.
Dann sind sie am meckern, so nach dem Motto,
Alter, ach, was hat der schon gemacht?
Hätte ich auch machen können. Haben sie aber nicht.
Das finde ich bei Hardwarerad eigentlich ganz cool.
Da hat's gesagt, hey, ich kenn mich mit der Geschichte aus.
Ich hab Zeit.
Ob er das Geld für hat, weiß ich nicht.
Aber scheint ja zu funktionieren.
Und er macht das einfach.
Und ich denke, das kann man auch mal unterstützen.
Ich finde das gut, dass er das macht.
Ich finde das echt nice, wie er das mit seinem Job managt.
So von nichts zu
was quasi.
Und wenn ihm das Tool hilft dabei,
ist doch super.
Und ich hör schon die ersten Leute,
die dann wieder rummeckern, so nach dem Motto,
was ist da schon dabei?
Er hat doch einfach nur einen Hardware-Shop, bla bla bla.
So nach dem Motto, um da schlecht zu reden,
so, kann doch jeder.
Aber kann eben nicht jeder.
Wenn's jeder könnte, warum macht's dann nicht jeder?
Weil sie entweder zu faul sind, es doch nicht können
oder keinen Bock haben. Und er macht's.
Es klappt.
Ob's langfristig klappt, muss ich rausstellen, werden wir noch sehen.
Aber ich find's auf jeden Fall cool.
Deswegen kann mir eben der helfen bei.
Eventuell ausgeben lassen,
wie viel doppelte Keys vorhanden sind.
Können wir noch machen, ja.
So, ich muss mir jetzt erst mal überlegen,
wie krieg ich jetzt raus...
Oh, mir tut die Zunge weh. Das mit dem Zahlen ist wirklich nervig.
Ähm...
Wie krieg ich jetzt raus,
ob wir
Lizenzen haben,
also ob wir eine Lizenz entfernen können.
Wir können theoretisch eine Lizenz
entfernen, wenn in
unused...
unused licenses
ähm...
wenn dort
die license
nirgendswo hier drin ist.
Also sprich,
ich nehm ja alle
Lizenzen und gucke,
ob sie in dem Input drin sind,
der gepusht wurde.
Sind sie nicht in dem Input drin, der gepusht wurde,
bedeutet das, sie wurden
entfernt und ich kann sie löschen.
Ich hoffe, das funktioniert so.
Das wird jetzt ein bisschen
ein ekliger, äh...
unique lines.
Any...
Jetzt haben wir lines und lines, äh...
Nehmen wir das mal...
Key...
Wie nennen wir das?
Wir nennen das U...
Key...
Not...
So, und das müsste mir jetzt von der Idee
kommen, ja manchmal ist link schon ganz cool,
ähm, das müsste mir jetzt alle Sachen geben,
die beim Pushen entfernt wurden.
So, dann sagen wir remove range.
Mal gucken, ob das
funktioniert.
Context remove range.
Save.
Okay, mal gucken, ob das jetzt klappt.
Kennt sich
irgendwer mit Kopfhörer und Mikrofon aus?
Was, ähm...
Willst du ein Mikrofon und Kopfhörer
oder willst du ein Headset?
Also wenn du Kopfhörer...
oder willst du ein Mikrofilz und Kopf...
Kopfhörer, also...
Der Geheimtipp ist ja immer noch
bei den Kopfhörern für kleines Geld, die
Superlux Dinger.
Guckt, funktioniert, nice.
Doppeltes Zeug hinzufügen
geht nicht.
Vier, fünf...
Funktioniert.
Und jetzt löschen wir mal irgendwas.
Geht auch.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, passt.
Fertig. Ähm...
Das mit dem Split on Client
könnte man vielleicht trotzdem noch irgendwann machen.
Okay.
Also ich würde sagen, so die Verwaltung für
Keys können wir jetzt erstmal so lassen.
Das, was vorhin...
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der hieß, gesagt hat.
Gabi Ralli, das baue ich...
Da muss ich mir noch ein bisschen Gedanken zu machen,
wie wir das machen können, dass wir noch Kommentare hinzufügen.
Damit brauchen wir irgendwie den Import-Button.
Okay, ähm...
Gut.
Jetzt müssen wir mal testen, wie das...
Aktivieren funktioniert.
Also beziehungsweise unseren...
unseren Client, der eigentlich aktivieren soll.
Ja.
Search for keyserver.
So, wo sind wir denn hier stehen geblieben?
Delete.
Ah, das machen wir übrigens auch falsch, ist mir eingefallen.
Wir wollen die Lizenz...
Wenn wir sagen delete, wollen wir nicht
wirklich deleten, sondern
wir wollen...
Wir wollen die Leisten auf used setzen.
Used at.
Ja, jetzt gerade wurde die benutzt.
Das können wir nämlich später in der Auswertung ordentlich
einfügen.
Jetzt sagen wir nicht removed, sondern einfach save.
Gut ist.
Was hast du verpasst?
Wir haben noch nicht allzu lang angefangen.
Die Key-Verwaltung geht jetzt.
Okay, ähm...
Also, wir aktivieren
jetzt mal...
Oh, license...
Okay, gucken wir nochmal, ob das theoretisch funktioniert.
Activate, yes.
Ah, hat's entfernt, guckt.
245.
Wir gehen auch mit dem
SQLite Explorer dran.
Äh, warum löscht der noch?
Der soll nicht mal löschen.
Ist nicht verschrieben.
Wartet mal, hä?
Yes.
Okay, der Key hier verschwindet.
Hä?
Ich glaube, ich muss das Ding mal starten neu.
Ich hab das nicht neu gestartet, seitdem ich das hier auf
umgestellt hab.
Okay, fügen wir nochmal ein paar
Fake-Windows-Keys hinzu.
Save.
Na gut, die Reihenfolge ist ja scheißegal.
Erstmal, die sieht nicht schön aus.
Aber Windows-Keys sind eh random.
Ja, da müssen wir uns
noch ein bisschen was Schöneres überlegen.
Ähm...
Kann man hier refreshen?
Ja.
So, und jetzt...
Starten.
Activate, yes.
Ob das jetzt funktioniert? Warte mal, irgendwas...
Hä?
Irgendwas hab ich verkehrt gemacht.
Ah!
Ne, hat funktioniert.
Jetzt hat er den Key gesetzt auf used at.
Also sprich, wenn das Aktivieren geklappt hat,
von der Windows-Lizenz,
dann setzt er die Zeit, wann es aktiviert wurde.
Das heißt, ich hab hier einen Fehler
in meinem Filter drin.
Ja, siehste?
Wir wollen nämlich where,
wo es nicht used ist.
Nur die Lizenzen, die nicht used sind.
Okay.
Ähm...
Jetzt gucken wir nochmal, was funktioniert.
Ups, wow.
Piss dich, Alter.
So, aktivieren.
Yes.
Äh, ich hab nicht zugeguckt, ist gerade ein Key verschwunden?
Ist gerade ein Key verschwunden, oder nicht?
Yes.
Ja! Nice!
Key ist weg.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Äh...
Ich muss mal search for key server.
Key found.
So, und da schreiben wir jetzt
license info
key.
Genau. Da zeigt er nämlich nochmal den
Key an.
Und jetzt kann man sagen, activate.
Yes, no. Read key.
Pressed key.
Wenn der
Key...
So, wie oft das Wort key... äh...
Wenn der Key gleich yes ist,
dann machen wir weiter.
So, und hier
Windows aggravaten.
An der Stelle.
So, hier sind wir fertig.
Machen wir...
Wir machen unten noch einen Sleep rein, dass das Ding
nochmal kurz, ähm...
Das ist zwar nicht schön, aber wir machen nochmal einen Sleep rein,
dass es einfach nochmal kurz
eine Sekunde offen bleibt am Ende und sich dann
beendet.
Wenn wir mal Windows aktiviert haben, yes.
Jetzt muss alles hier rein.
Hier müssen wir Windows aktivieren.
Aber wenn wir schon mal no gepresst haben,
dann wollen wir auch gar nicht aktivieren.
Also sprich, wenn wir sagen no,
dann geht er direkt raus.
No.
Okay, das funktioniert.
Ähm, so.
If activating geklappt,
dann werden wir es löschen.
Also beziehungsweise, wenn das
aktivieren geklappt hat, dann
werden wir... Jetzt müssen wir erstmal rauskriegen,
wie man mit C sharp feststellen kann,
ob Windows aktiviert ist.
Da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt, wie das funktioniert.
Da müssen wir Stack Overflow.
Alter, warum gucken mir 160 Leute zu?
Krasser Scheiß.
Nice, dass so viele dabei sind.
Ich guck mal. Nicht, dass ich mir da die Follows
und sonstige Dinger übersehe.
Da bin ich ja bekannt für den Krams zu übersehen.
Äh, haben wir hier.
Steamlabs machen wir mal auf.
Noch nicht mal auf alles.
Steamlabs und tippiestream.
Ja, danke für die ganzen Follows.
Ich sehe leider bloß die letzten paar.
Äh...
FreshAlex und
White3, Sir
Hoser und Toito.
Die anderen waren angeblich schon gestern.
Ähm, vielleicht gab es auch einfach nicht mehr.
Kann auch sein. Ähm...
Schön, dass ihr dabei seid im Stream.
Wenn mir meine Zunge
heute nicht so weh tut, oder?
Okay, wie können wir checken mit C sharp,
ob Windows aktiviert ist?
Stack Overflow Fragen.
Programmatically
check
Windows 7 activated.
Slee API.
Was ist das?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Könnte der Dude nicht mal ein Beispiel
schreiben?
Was zum Teufel ist C-Script?
Ja, und wie...
Oh, die Ärzte sind durch.
Tja, da müssen wir was anderes anmachen.
Dann machen wir wieder unseren 24-7
Chillsource-Stream an.
Okay, wie genau funktioniert man...
Das ist bestimmt irgendeine
C-API-Geschichte wieder, oder?
Äh...
Na, das machen wir ganz bestimmt nicht.
Da muss es eine schönere Variante geben.
Warum...
Warum ist das unter Windows alles immer so kompliziert?
Ah, guck mal, da hat schon einer was Fertiges gebastelt.
Wir gucken uns das jetzt einfach mal
von ihm ab.
Ah, endlich mal einer, der seine Dateien auch ordentlich benennt.
Was geht mit dem Dude ab?
Ich will einfach nur gucken, ob Windows aktiviert ist.
Das muss anders gehen.
How to check license data
in Windows 20 Sharp.
Windows ist aktiviert.
Jawoll! Copy-Paste.
Stack-Overflow-Driven sind wir heute.
Copy-Paste. Beste.
Was macht der denn hier?
Gucken wir uns das erst mal an.
Was macht der denn da eigentlich?
Management-Scope.
Ah, losen.
Management-Environment-Machine-Name.
Blub.
Connect.
Was macht der da überhaupt?
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Was genau macht der?
Application-ID in UID.
License-Datus 1.
What?
Und das soll funktionieren?
Ok.
Gucken wir mal.
Ist Windows Activated?
Sollte uns jetzt eigentlich True rauskommen.
Macht gar nichts.
Hängt.
Na geil.
Vielleicht ist es einfach nur langsam.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Moment.
Braucht Windows wirklich 10 Sekunden um zu checken,
ob es aktiviert ist?
Warum? Was ist das wieder?
Was ist das für Magic-Code wieder?
Ok.
Es funktioniert anscheinend.
Also erstens ist es saumäßig langsam.
Und zweitens, ich habe keine Ahnung, was es tut.
Man muss doch irgendwie
ernsthaft, jetzt mal ernsthaft, Leute.
Man muss doch irgendwie normal
checken können,
ob Windows aktiviert ist.
Der Typ macht das genauso mit
Woher haben die hier diese Magic-ID?
Was ist das?
Woher weiß man das?
Warum ist da eine Ducky One Skyline auf?
Weil ich zeigen wollte,
was ich für eine Tastatur geholt habe für die Arbeit.
Also da muss es doch irgendwas
schöneres geben.
Also gefallen tut mir das nicht, aber ich meine
es geht. Wir lassen es erstmal so.
Stack Overflow, Copy-Paste.
Beste.
Komplett Magie hier oben wieder.
Komplett Magic.
Key found.
Want to
activate Windows now?
Fragezeichen.
Yes, No.
So, wenn
aktivieren funktioniert hat,
das kriegen wir hier mit raus.
Is Windows activated?
Done.
Dann
setzen wir den Key auf Use.
Done.
So, das müsste eigentlich unser Activator-Programm sein.
Bis aufs eigentliche Activaten.
So.
Search for Key Server.
Da schreiben wir noch irgendwie
Server Info found.
Server Info. Mal gucken.
Endpoint.
IP.
Found.
Oh ja.
Key found.
Wie haben wir den Kram genannt?
Server Info.
Ah,
plus.
Key found.
Want to
activate Windows now?
Okay. Yes.
Enter.
Ah, der
hängt jetzt. Der hängt jetzt, weil er Windows
Aktivierung checkt. Warum dauert der Scheiß so
lang, wenn du das Aktivierung checkst?
Okay, hat nicht
funktioniert, oder?
Oh, hat funktioniert. Ich gebe bloß keine Meldung aus.
Ich noob.
Hat funktioniert. Guckst, Leute, ist nur noch ein Key drin.
Hat funktioniert.
Fügen wir mal wieder ein paar Keys ein.
Ja.
Wir könnten übrigens den Check
gegen alle Keys mal laufen lassen.
Weil die
müssten eigentlich alle Unix sein.
Ah, nicer Artikel, Paddy.
Puppke. Allerdings, das ist ja noch
komplizierter, ne?
Ach nee, ah.
Die machen das mit dieser komischen
SL
API
Geschichte.
Ja, aber ich lasse das jetzt erstmal so.
Ganz ehrlich.
Die 5 Sekunden hat man nach dem Aktivierungsprozess
auch noch übrig.
So, dann geben wir jetzt
irgendwie noch sowas aus wie Activation.
Wir geben einfach aus
Success.
Und dann sagen wir
mark key as used.
Fertig.
Okay.
Ah, bla bla.
Search for keyserver found.
Getting key from.
Machen wir noch ein Leerzeichen rein.
Alter, 165.
Krasse Scheiße, wie viele Leute
hier zugucken.
Checkt überhaupt irgendjemand, was ich hier mache?
Also ich weiß, es gibt genug, die es checken.
Wer checkt
nicht, was ich hier mache?
Woher weiß ich, ob ich eine Arraylist oder
Array benutzen muss?
Ich habe keinen Plan vom Programmieren und bin mitten im 1. September.
Dann wird es jetzt Zeit,
das Ganze zu lernen.
Also in C-Sharp
beziehungsweise .NET
ist es relativ einfach, eine Arraylist verwendet man nicht mehr.
Arraylist ist .NET 1.0.
Achso, Java. Keine Ahnung.
Nee, localhost wird nicht funktionieren.
Jaja,
der schreibt die Server-URL rein,
auf die er läuft.
Ich kann ihm einfach sagen,
er soll dort die
IP von dem Server
reinschreiben, auf die er gerade läuft.
So.
Want to activate Windows
now? Yes.
Enter.
Ok, da müssen wir
noch irgendein Waiting oder so einblenden.
Success.
Jawoll.
Dann machen wir es hier nur.
Press any key to
exit.
Console
read key.
Ok, nice.
Das funktioniert prinzipiell.
Ähm.
Hier müssen wir noch anzeigen, dass er
das erwartet.
Activating.
Want to activate now. Yes, activating.
Mein Gott, das Abfragen
lange, ey. Das Abfragen braucht ja fast länger als das Aktivieren.
Mark key as used.
Press any key to exit.
Nice.
No.
Hat das Tool eigentlich auch Raytracing?
Du meinst, ob das
RTX on enabled ist, das Tool?
Das Tool nicht. Allerdings.
Mein
DirectX GIF Player, der
kann natürlich in Zukunft auch Raytracing.
Wozu immer man das brauchen soll.
Error Handling. What?
Achso, wobei.
Naja. So wirklich viele Fehler
kann es an der Stelle gar nicht geben. Das einzige, was
passieren kann, ist, dass er selber nicht antwortet.
Und dann kackt es ab.
Was aber auch ok ist.
Schauen wir mal Abfragen nach welcher
Dienst so lange braucht.
Ok.
Prozess Explorer auf und gucken, welcher Dienst
so lange braucht zum Aktivieren.
Ok, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Want to activate.
Yes.
Das da.
SPP
SVC.
SPP SVC.
Was ist das?
Praxistipp Chip.
Um was es sich beim Windows Prozess
SPP SVC handelt,
ist ein Windows Dienst.
Der Prozess heißt bla bla bla bla bla.
Das Tool ist dafür zuständig,
digitale Lizenzen runterzuladen.
Na ok. Der geht wahrscheinlich
zu Microsoft und guckt, ob das wirklich aktiviert ist.
Das Windows.
Dass man das nicht faken kann oder so.
So.
So und das Aktivieren werden
wir jetzt folgendermaßen machen.
Wir faken das jetzt gerade mal. Allerdings so möglichst
realistisch, wie es irgendwie geht.
Und dann probieren wir es in unserer VM aus.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt drauf.
Also machen wir hier Process.
Zeige ich euch mal was.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal, wie man Admin.
Mir tut echt die Zunge weh. Das ist übelst kacke.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal,
wie ihr einen Prozess starten könnt.
Und
quasi in der laufenden
Anwendung für den neuen Prozess
Adminrechte anfordern könnt.
Und zwar
erstmal müsst ihr sagen hier
Prozess Start Info
und dann halt, was er starten soll.
In dem Fall starten wir einfach mal eine CMD.
Und dann, das ist das Wichtige,
musste ich nämlich auch mal nachgucken bei
Stack Overflow. Wusste ich aus dem Kopf auch nicht.
Jetzt kann man sagen, Verb, übelst
Arcane Magic wieder, Run S.
Wenn man das da vorschreibt,
also wenn man den Run S da vorschreibt,
dann fragt
er nach Adminberechtigung an für den neuen Prozess.
Weil,
bei Windows
gibt es sowas wie Wait.
Ah, ja, ja.
Da habe ich das Richtige für dich.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt
funktioniert.
Want to activate Windows. Ihr seht es nicht,
ne?
Aber, ich habe jetzt eine Admin Shell.
Hat funktioniert. Und wenn
die zu geht, das ist dann halt quasi
das Aktivierungsding.
Wenn die zu geht, dann checkt
er Prozess.
Ja, wir könnten,
wir könnten, ich habe eine Idee.
Was wir hier noch machen könnten,
wir könnten,
hat man gehört? Okay.
Wir könnten wirklich
noch ein Progress anzeigen.
Also irgendwie sowas.
Mal gucken, wie wir das gescheit machen.
Warte mal,
mal gucken.
Da muss ich
jetzt mal kurz ausprobieren. Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie wir das gescheit machen.
Wollen wir jetzt mal eine Progress Bar
anzeigen?
Oder, wir zeigen erst,
wir zeigen erst mal den Status an, ja?
While not cancel.
Sleep.
Irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 100.
Machen wir das mal ganz billig,
nur um zu gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Und jetzt Console
write
Punkt.
Jetzt solltet ihr Punkt, Punkt, Punkt schreiben.
Bis ich,
bis ich,
cancel auf
true setze.
Gucken wir mal, ob das klappt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
You want to activate Windows? Yes.
Huh?
Huh? Huh?
Status Bar.
Krasser Shit, oder?
Poggers. Das ist doch cool.
Übrigens, der,
das ist, das ist der Node,
das ist die Node.js
Progress Bar. Kennt ihr die
Node.js Progress Bar? Die haben irgendwie
ein bisschen,
weiß nicht, wie macht man das?
Mir fällt jetzt nichts anderes ein, wenn wir das machen.
Gucken wir mal, ob die schöner aussieht.
Was genau
ist falsch gemacht?
Ah, man muss den Kram esketten.
Ach nee, Moment.
Das geht so nicht.
Wir müssen, wir müssen,
wir müssen
quasi ein,
ein Zeichen irgendwie zurück machen, oder?
Wann geht das wahrscheinlich?
Das ist das,
was ist das für ein Gefrickel hier?
Hä?
Ich würde gerne einen Carriage Turn machen.
Ach, scheiß drauf, wir bleiben bei Punkten.
Wir bleiben bei Punkten.
Punkte reichen auch.
Ah, Punkte.
Alle 250 Millisekunden ein Punkt und gut ist.
Müsste,
müsste B sein, okay.
War das nicht B? Ja doch, kann, kann sein.
Machen einen Flugzeug.
Oh, Emojis, jawohl.
Kann eigentlich die Windows-Kommando-Zeile mittlerweile Emojis?
Alter, guck mal, wie lange das
Scheiß dauert, ey.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich jetzt schon bei Microsoft geblockt,
weil ich so oft anfrage.
Das hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Ach nee, weil ich den, weil ich die Shell nicht zumache.
Kann Windows,
kann die Windows-Shell Emojis?
Nee.
Oh, sind wir rückständig, Microsoft.
Warum ist Microsoft so rückständig,
was das angeht?
Kann es das PowerShell-Fenster?
Nee.
Ah.
Das ist aber ganz, ganz schlecht.
Kann Bash Emojis sein?
Bash muss, Bash ist die Shell.
Die kann alle möglichen Zeichen, die du ihr gibst.
Ob dann Terminal Emojis kann?
Ja, und die meisten Terminals können mittlerweile noch die Linux-Emojis.
Meint ihr an der Schriftart liegt's?
Können wir mal ausprobieren.
Äh, Font.
Se, Se, Segui,
Dingsbums, nee.
Ist ja was Scheiß auf Emojis.
Wir mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich's hier reinschreibe.
Nee, guck.
Der kann's nicht.
Fail.
Microsoft, fail.
Cmd, Display, Emojis.
Wie geht das? Ich will wissen, wie das geht.
Das ist doch nicht live.
Guck mal, wenn die am 18.7.
Vielleicht kommt das mit dem Oktober-Update.
Ja, mit dem Oktober-Update
geht das wahrscheinlich.
Wenn es, wenn es quasi
im Juni in Insider Builds war,
da ist es wahrscheinlich im Oktober-Update dabei.
Progress.
Dann probieren wir das mit dem Oktober-Update nochmal aus.
Aber,
so müssen wir uns mit Punkten,
so müssen wir uns mal mit Punkten
auseinandersetzen.
Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Geht nicht? Oh, Scheiße.
Okay. So, und jetzt testen wir mal
das Act, das Activaten
auf der zweiten Kiste.
So, wie ist denn der richtige
Befehl zum Activaten überhaupt?
SLMGR oder so, ne?
So.
Äh, TeraFox, wieso, was hast du geschrieben?
Kannst du CMD, ja?
Glaube auch nicht.
Wie macht man nochmal die Bildschirmtastatur auf?
Wisst ihr das?
Ah, hier.
Onscreen.
Emojis, wie macht man Emojis?
Wie geht das? Ich habe noch nie über diese,
über dieses komische Windows-Ding Emojis eingefügt.
Wie, wie kommt man jetzt hier
auf Emojis, Options?
Äh.
Windows plus Punkt, okay.
Oh.
Doch.
CMD, ja kann's.
Äh.
Fast. Debated.
Okay, wir müssen erstmal ausprobieren,
ob das funktioniert.
Ich hoffe, ich deaktiviere mein Windows jetzt nicht.
Deswegen schalte ich den Admin-Modus mal aus.
Kann man das überhaupt so ausführen?
CM, so.
SLMGR
VBS, Official Basic
Script, Official Basic Script,
das ist das Schlimmste, was es gibt.
Okay, wenn ich das so ausführe, passiert ja wahrscheinlich nichts.
Error.
Request Action Requires
Elevated Privilege.
Okay, das ist gut, das ist gut.
Ich will ja mein Windows nicht deaktivieren.
So, und an der Stelle
wollen wir jetzt natürlich nicht reinschreiben,
einfach so, sondern den
LicenseInfo
Punkt
Key brauchen wir an der Stelle.
Und da müssen wir
sagen, Process
StartInfo
Shell. Use Shell.
Okay, er kann das Ganze
nicht ausführen. Warum nicht?
Windows, warum nicht?
Ah, ich habe IPK
vergessen.
Okay, Windows, wo ist das Problem?
Cannot find
File, also muss ich wahrscheinlich
CMD
Ach du Scheiße.
StackOverflow
RunCommandLinePromptCommands
FileNameCMDExArguments
Aha, so rum macht man das.
Warum
gibt es da auch immer Use Shell to execute?
Bei Microsoft.
Man weiß es nicht.
Also, FileNameCMDArguments
Das da.
Oder? Ne, warte.
Wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Ah, Moment.
Windows, please!
CMD
Okay, was muss ich machen?
C Mama Echo 1
Okay, anscheinend muss man
Slash C dran machen.
Slash C
Okay, ob das so funktioniert? Ich weiß es ja nicht.
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Hey!
Es funktioniert!
Wie kriege ich denn
den Exit-Code von dem Prozess?
Es hat doch bestimmt
einen Exit-Code.
Exit-Code, nice.
Want to activate Windows, yes!
Fehler, Fehler, Fehler.
Okay, ich vermute, man hat einen Exit-Code von
Minus, bla, also einen Exit-Code
Null ist wahrscheinlich auch unter Windows
Kacke, oder? Gucken wir mal.
Echo 1, was da rauskommt.
Null, ja, gut.
Also, Exit-Code muss
Null sein von dem Programm.
Und, ähm,
Windows muss
Activated danach sein. Dann passt das
eigentlich.
Alter, 180
Leute! Wo kommen die eigentlich alle her?
Hat mich irgendjemand gehostet und ich habe es übersehen?
Ne, keine Host oder was?
Sehr nice, dass ihr alle
am Start seid heute.
Das ist wirklich, äh, absolut massiv.
Coggers und Poggers
und alles zusammen, was es da gibt.
Und vor allem, sehr easy.
Easy.
Aus der Zukunft.
200 Viewer Face Reveal.
Ne.
Eine Million YouTube-Abos.
Okay, jetzt probieren wir das Ganze mal auf
unserer VM aus, ob das funktioniert.
Okay, wir starten jetzt
den...
Starten jetzt das ASP.NET Ding.
Okay.
Dann gehen wir hier
Bin Debug
Coggers.
Okay.
Das heißt, den ganzen Schmodder
kopieren wir uns jetzt mal auf unsere VM.
Wo ist unsere VM? Hier.
Bam.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Nice, nice.
Oh.
Warum kackt das ab?
Der kackt ab,
weil er sich nicht zum Web-Server verbinden kann.
Ach, Localhost. Alter.
Leute, ich sag's noch, wir müssen's ändern.
Ich sag noch, wir müssen's ändern.
Aber...
Ah, Leute.
Lull.
Omega-Lull.
Okay.
Ähm.
Wir machen erstmal meine IP...
Nee, warte mal. Wie kriegt man...
Siehschau ab, wie kriegt man die Local-IP raus?
So, komm.
So machen wir das.
Und das Schöne daran ist, man sieht jetzt schon,
man muss an dem Client nichts ändern.
Na, also wenn ich das jetzt starte,
wenn ich das jetzt starte,
es wird jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder nicht funktionieren,
ob's falsch, falscher Desktop.
Und ich geh jetzt wieder zu meinem Client.
Da seht ihr, der discovered den neuen Server automatisch.
Der kann sich allerdings da immer noch nicht hin verbinden.
Weil, ähm,
ich ASP.NET Core nicht gesagt habe,
er soll an der externen IP lauschen.
Aber das machen wir jetzt gleich.
Mal gucken, was passiert.
Wahrscheinlich timeoutet der jetzt gleich.
Denk ich mal.
Wahrscheinlich timeoutet der, ja genau.
Der timeoutet.
Das heißt, ich muss erstmal
als ASP.NET Core noch sagen,
binde dich mal
an die externe IP.
Und das gucken wir uns einfach ab.
Useworlds, genau.
So.
Jetzt lauscht er an Port 5001.
Sehr nice.
Global an Port 5001.
Oder auch nicht.
Hängt das?
Hängt, oder?
Ah.
Port 5000.
Statt 5001.
Aha.
Da sind wir wieder.
So, mal gucken, ob ich vom anderen
Rechner aus drauf komme.
Ja, komme ich.
Okay, und jetzt gehen wir nochmal
in unsere VM und gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Wäre nicht lokal, doch klar.
Also ne, die eigene IP
machen wir.
So, mal gucken, ob jetzt das
Activaten funktioniert.
Ah, ah, ah.
Seht ihr, found key.
Hat den Key vom Server abgerufen.
Want to activate, yes.
Ja okay, das Aktivieren geht jetzt natürlich nicht.
Weil wir keinen Key haben.
Sonst könnten wir das ausprobieren.
Wir haben keinen Key.
Wenn wir
jetzt einen Key einfügen,
der legit ist, ist der Key instant weg,
while on stream.
Oh, my English sucks.
I cannot stream in English.
Aber prinzipiell seht ihr, das funktioniert.
Allerdings ist
das ein bisschen
fail.
Mein Timer geht nicht aus.
Was habe ich verkackt?
Nö, du brauchst nichts vorinstalliert.
Musst einfach nur den
Server ausführen im gleichen Netz,
wo du die Clients installierst. Fertig.
Nimm doch nen KMS.
Das ist nicht meine Entscheidung.
Ich bastle den Jungs bloß was,
dass sie das Leben einfacher haben.
Mit dem, was sie jetzt haben.
Oh, jetzt ist der Translator
am Start.
Was habe ich
hier kaputt gemacht? Cancel.
Ah ja.
Soll auf jeden Fall
gecancelt werden. Immer.
Egal, ob das Activate klappt oder nicht.
Zum Testen.
Echt? Ernsthaft? Was ist das für ein Key?
Ist das ein
Trial-Key oder was?
Ist das ein Trial-Key, mit dem man das ausprobieren kann?
Können wir mal ausprobieren.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Wenn es damit zum Testen
geht, wäre natürlich sehr nice.
Irgendwas SLM...
SLMGR
VBS
IPX
Oh ne.
Windows. Eingabe aus.
Vorerfolgung.
Warum ist das so schlecht zu benutzen?
Äh. Was ist das?
IPK ist es.
IPK. Nicht IPX. IPK.
I
P
K
What? Und das sogar ohne Admin-Rechte?
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur, weil es Fake ist, oder?
Ach ne.
Ich bin der Admin.
Nice. Das ist cool zum Testen.
Das ist wirklich cool zum Testen.
Äh. Aktiviert das
jetzt so?
Ersetzt den vorhandenen Key. Ah. ATO ist aktivieren.
Ah. Verstehe. Verstehe.
Fehler. Der DNS-Name
ist nicht vorhanden.
Was für ein DNS-Name?
Hä?
Habe ich kein DNS drin?
Doch. Habe ich.
Okay. Keine Ahnung. Aber das geht wahrscheinlich nicht,
weil das jetzt kein offizieller Key ist.
Na. Start die VM
mal neu. Okay.
Aber das ist trotzdem ein cooler Key
zum Testen.
Warum gucken hier 200 Leute zu?
Was geht denn heute ab?
Krasser Scheiß.
Heftige Sache.
Kommen die denn alle her?
Habt ihr den Channel
so gefunden?
Über Twitter? Einfach in der Science
and Technology Kategorie?
Oder seid ihr über YouTube da?
Oder seid ihr über Twitter da?
200. Krasser Poggas.
Äh. Twitter hier.
Ey. Keiner hat
was von 200 Viewern Cam gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt 1 Million Abos auf YouTube, dann Cam.
Kann man irgendwie
mit diesem SLMGR
kann man da irgendwie checken, ob Windows aktiviert ist?
Ah.
XPR. Ablaufdatum.
Okay. Ja gut.
Also prinzipiell
scheint das echt zu funktionieren,
was ich hier gebastelt habe.
Wir tragen jetzt mal den...
Ups. Warum ist denn das aus?
Ist ausgelöst?
Ist ausgemacht?
Progress. Wir tragen das jetzt mal hier ein.
Ah. Das hat jetzt
als letzter Key drinne.
Wir löschen einfach nochmal alles.
Ja. Das Keyhandling
braucht noch ein bisschen Verbesserung.
Ah. Jetzt haben wir den Key hier drinne.
Machen wir nochmal ein paar Fake Keys wieder unten drunter.
Ah.
Und jetzt aktivieren wir den Kram nochmal.
So.
Wir müssen es nämlich noch auf markiert setzen.
Also Windows aktiviert ist.
Und der Exit Code 0.
Dann...
Äh. Windows.
Krams weg machen hier.
Ich mache euch da auch nur eine Exit raus.
Ihr braucht nicht den ganzen Mist kopieren dann.
Beziehungsweise ihr müsst überhaupt nicht kopieren.
Ihr müsst es einfach in euren Installer einbauen.
Also überprüft ihr,
ob es aktiviert ist.
Und es ist nicht aktiviert,
weil es halt nicht überprüfen kann.
Tja.
Das kann ich hier nicht nachstellen.
Das müsst ihr morgen mal ausprobieren.
Ob das funktioniert.
Das müsst ihr nachher mal nachbauen.
Ähm.
Mal nachher ausprobieren.
Das kann ich von hier nicht machen.
Das kann man nur testen mit einem wirklich fehlenden Windows Key.
Ah. Ein ATO noch hinten dran.
Ah ja. Ok.
Stimmt.
Run as brauchen wir nicht.
Ihr lasst es ja eher als Admin laufen.
Wie verbindet man
mit der Windows Shell zwei Befehle?
Ich meine mit Bash würde ich es so machen.
Command.
Wir benutzen mal Template Strings.
Damit ist das Ganze ein bisschen schöner.
Ne, wir sind nicht in JavaScript.
Was waren sie Sharp?
Template Strings nochmal.
War es vielleicht doch so?
Ne, das war JavaScript.
Wie sah ein Template Strings in C Sharp nochmal aus?
Oder war das einfach ganz normal so?
Ne.
Ich kann es mir nicht merken.
Ach ja.
Dings davor.
Was ist das?
License Info Key.
So.
Und jetzt hinten dran.
Kann man sowas machen einfach?
Dass er das nacheinander ausführt?
Geht das?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Also Echo 1.
Echo 2.
Ah.
Das geht unter Windows auch?
Das ist ja nice.
Das geht unter Windows auch. Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja, dann ist das nice.
Ok.
Das müsste jetzt funktionieren.
Das müssen wir morgen vielleicht
noch ein bisschen testen, ob das geht, weil das ist halt
die einzige Sache, die ich hier bei mir
nicht gescheit testen kann.
Ja, ich habe noch meine hardcoded IP
drinne. Die müssen wir jetzt ersetzen durch die Server
IP.
Da.
Wie kriegt man am besten
in C Sharp die eigene IP?
Keine Login IP
Address. Wow.
Das muss das wieder komplizieren.
Kann man nicht einfach sagen
IP
Local oder so.
Ich meine gut, es könnte ja sein, dass wir mehrere
Netzwerkkarten haben.
Dann ist nicht ganz klar, welche wir nehmen müssen.
Was ist das hier? Warum ist das
wieder so kompliziert, eine lokale IP zu kriegen?
Gucken wir mal, was da rauskommt jetzt.
IP Host Entry.
Gucken wir mal, wie wir das gescheit
rauskriegen, die lokale IP.
Das ist dein GIF Player.
Ne, der GIF Player ist eigentlich fertig.
Und ich habe ihn auch schon teilweise
eingebaut in das Meme Tool.
Address List.
First.
Kann ich auch mal sagen. First und gut ist.
Oh ne, IPv6.
Brauchen wir in dem Fall nicht.
Okay, es ist doch
nicht so einfach, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe, die lokale
IP raus zu kriegen.
Address List.
Ah, da.
Ja.
Ja, das ist richtig, TeraFox, es geht bestimmt.
Ähm.
Wie wähle ich denn jetzt aus, was die beste
IP ist?
Kannst du für die erste Version auch IP DNS fest reinschreiben?
Kann ich machen.
Kann ich machen, ja.
Schickt mir einfach mal
irgendwo
eure IP dann.
Da füge ich das nachher noch ein, bevor ich euch das
nachher schicke.
Gut, dann lassen wir es jetzt erstmal so.
Und wir bauen das Web Interface noch ein bisschen schöner.
Wir bauen das Web Interface
noch ein bisschen schöner.
Weil da fehlt ja noch ganz viel.
Guckt mal.
Weil aktuell gibt es hier einfach eine Key Anzeige.
Logs und Stats ist noch gar nichts drin.
Also Logs sollten wir zumindest jetzt mal machen.
Okay, mache ich.
Mache ich, ja.
Ähm.
Logs schreiben wir noch rein.
Was denn?
Also sprich,
wer denn wie wo geused hat.
Achso, eine Sache wollte
ich ja noch machen. Wir müssen noch mal
aktivieren.
Oder neu fake
Und zwar
will ich ja noch den Rechner Namen übermitteln.
Da habe ich mir vorher schon rausgesucht, wie man das Ganze
gescheit machen kann.
Nämlich so.
Ups.
So gibt es den aktuellen Rechner Name.
Falsches Projekt. Gehe fort.
Ja. Username und
PC Gedöns.
Weil das
übergeben wir dem Ganzen noch
beim Deleten.
MAC Adresse. Klar, das können wir auch machen.
MAC Adresse
ist eine coole Idee. Ist eigentlich viel besser.
Ähm.
Wie kriegt man
die, wie kriegt man
die MAC raus?
Wahrscheinlich so wie eben.
Das geht bestimmt anders.
Network Interface
is get all Network Interface.
Das
ist doch auch viel schöner.
Network Interface.
IP.
ID. Name.
Wie kriegt man denn jetzt, da kriegt man wahrscheinlich
doch auch so die IP raus.
Ah. Operational Status.
Up. Das ist schon mal ganz interessant.
Weil dann sieht man nämlich nur die Netzwerk Interface
wo was eingestöpselt ist.
Up. Up. Okay.
Physical Address.
Ja. Nice.
Bei mehreren Netzwerkern habe ich mehrere MAC Adressen.
Aber Up dürfte doch
eigentlich nur
eine sein zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Ich meine das ist frisch installiert auf dem neuen Rechner.
Und Up ist nur die
wo ein Kabel drin steckt. Das kann eigentlich erstmal nur eine sein.
Ansonsten, wenn wir mehrere zur Auswahl
haben, dann
kurz gucken was welche Adapter ist.
Ah, das sind die VMware Adapters.
Gigabit
Up. 10 Gigabit
Up. Down. Down.
Ne. 10 Gigabit ist Down.
Ja. Gut so. Wollte ich gerade sagen. Steht nämlich gar nichts drin.
Passt doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Ja.
Down.
10 Gigabit ist Down.
Normale Internetzweckkarte ist Up.
Und die beiden VMware Adapter.
Loopback. Loopback muss ich nur rausfiltern.
Loopback braucht kein Mensch.
Ja. Hier kann man Loopback. Macht er nämlich hier auch an der Stelle.
Und hier sollte er Loopback
dann reinschreiben. Genau. Weil Loopback wollen wir nicht.
Okay. Da können wir uns wirklich ein ordentliches
Link draus basteln.
Ah. So kann man sagen.
Netzwerk Interface ist Where.
Interface
Status
gleich
Up.
Manchmal ist Link ganz praktisch.
Ähm.
Und
Interface Type
ungleich
Loopback.
Ungleich Loopback.
Ja. Das war es.
Und
davon nehmen wir einfach die
erste.
Bam. Fertig.
Wir machen es uns ganz einfach.
Interface.
Interfacer.
Interface. Interface.
Ach ne. Interface ist belegt.
Das darf man nicht. Übrigens.
Ihr könnt ein Add davor machen. Dann darf man
das in C Sharp auch Keywörter als
variablen Namen verwenden. Aber das will man
eigentlich nicht. If geht natürlich.
E-Face. Ist noch frei.
Get physical address.
Ok. Das ist meine
Mac. Kann man die ordentlich. Kann man die
irgendwie schöner formatieren?
Komm. Mal gucken ob das stimmt.
Wie sieht man das?
Wie sieht man das überhaupt richtig jetzt?
Windows. Ich weiß gar nicht mal wo man das überhaupt richtig
sieht. Ja.
Doch passt.
Microsoft sind auch die einzigen
die es entweder ohne Doppelpunkt oder mit Bindestrichen
schreiben. Ich kenn keinen der ist mit Bindestrichen.
Ich kenns eigentlich nur mit Doppelpunkt.
Ja. Es sei denn
Sorry da man hat 10G in der 2 Karte Onboard.
Das war der Grund warum ich das Board damals
genommen hab.
So. Und jetzt sagen wir noch
Select.
Ah.
Get physical address.
Und jetzt aber first.
Und dann steht der ganze
Krempel hier drinne.
Kann man das irgendwie noch schöner
formatieren die Mac?
Warum kauft man sich so nen. Achso. Ne. Du meinst nicht meins.
Doch. Meins. Meins.
Ja doch. Blow it up.
Warum nicht first get physical address.
Das ist eigentlich viel besser. Hast du recht.
Eigentlich schöner.
Genau. Schöner. Link Wurm.
Also ich hab von
Asrock. Ich hab von Asrock
nen Z370
Onboard mit 10G.
Ich weiß aber aus dem Kopf nicht mehr wie das heißt.
Aber ich hab ein Video gemacht wo man das
drin sehen kann.
Ich muss mir gleich noch was zu trinken holen.
Ups.
Fuck. Ich bin mit nem Stuhl über den Hals.
Übers Headset gefahren.
RIP Headset. Äh. RIP. RIP.
Ähm.
Eure Ohren.
So. Ich bin wieder da.
Ja. Nice.
Ja. Dann schreiben wir das Interface noch mit rein.
Wir nehmen das erste Interface
wo der Modus up ist.
Und der Netzwerktyp nicht loopback ist.
So krieg ich
doch bestimmt auch meine IP ordentlich raus.
Oder? Wie krieg ich denn hier meine.
Wie get ich denn. Get address bytes.
Ach ne.
Moment. Ähm.
Address.
IP.
Was? IPv4 statistics.
IP properties.
Da ist doch bestimmt die Adresse irgendwie dabei. Oder?
Oh ja. Ist das kompliziert.
Kann ich nicht einfach.
Unicast addresses.
Das klingt doch gut.
First. Gucken was da jetzt rauskommt.
Ne.
Address.
Ja. Das ist meine IP.
Sehr schön.
Ok. So könnte ich auch meine IP rauskriegen.
So.
Dann merken wir uns die MAC.
Wie könnte man das jetzt gescheit machen.
Wir könnten es. To string.
Kann man das vielleicht in Format angeben oder so.
Ne.
Aber wir können jetzt irgendwie sagen.
Split.
Oder. Hm. Hm.
Wie könnte man das jetzt
gescheit machen. Da muss man schon was überlegen.
Ich mein wir wollen eh alle 2
Bytes. Ich hol mal kurz was zu trinken.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Wenn ihr eine gute Idee habt. Wie man das richtig richtig schön elegant machen könnte.
Quasi.
Nach jedem 2.
Charakter.
Einen Doppelpunkt einfügen.
Dann seid mal kreativ.
Ich bin gleich wieder da. Ich hol mal was zu trinken.
So. Wieder da.
Oh ihr macht das alle mit Schleifen.
Irgendwie. Das muss doch schöner gehen. Oder?
Man kann to string irgendwelche Parameter geben.
Ne. Das ist ja kein Datum.
Oder so. Oh doch.
Kann das tatsächlich. Hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Ach ne. Das ist nur
für. Das ist irgendwie
nur wenn ich.
Irgendwelche.
Länder. Länderspezifischen Dinger.
Machen will.
Also lass mal überlegen. Wie könnte man das machen.
Hm.
Mal was suchen.
Also. Man könnte. Man könnte
Irgendwie. Ne. Man könnte irgendwie.
Irgendwie. Take.
Range. Was gibt's denn für
Möglichkeiten.
Ich will es mal ohne Doppelpunkte lassen.
Bis mir was gutes eingefallen ist.
Aber da muss es was schönes.
Kurzes knackiges dafür geben.
Das ist so ein schönes Problem.
Woran man sich ewig auslassen kann.
Bis man da was schönes gefunden hat.
Kann man. Gibt es kein Split?
Kein Split.
Jedes zweite Zeichen.
Ah mit. Ach.
Man kann sich die Bytes davon holen.
Ach so.
Aber das macht nach jedem.
Ja das ist eigentlich eine coole Idee.
Sagt Stack Overflow.
Ja.
Von der Idee her finde ich das cool.
Das ist Byte und das ist halt
Formatieren als Hex.
Achso.
Gucken ob das prinzipiell tut.
Ja 70. Ok.
Passt. Kann man den Join nicht hinten
dran machen.
Ach ne. Das ist ein SQL Join.
Vergesst's.
Aber man kann sagen toArrayJoin.
Oder?
Dann muss man es wohl wirklich so machen.
Wobei das nicht. Auch jetzt nicht das
Allerschönste ist. Irgendwie.
Äh. Hab ich irgendwo was vergessen?
Äh.
So viele Klammern. Da blinke ich dann mal durch.
Ich muss noch ein paar
Klammern wegmachen.
Ja.
Noch ne Klammer hin.
String Join.
Ach ne Separator muss ich noch angeben.
Klar.
Doppelpunkt.
Project.
Ich kann ja mal schreiben.
Oh das ist sehr sehr nice.
Mac.
Sehr sehr nice. Gefällt mir.
Das finde ich echt ganz schick so.
Jetzt haben wir die Mac.
Von der Kiste.
So und jetzt sagen wir ihm.
Also wir machen
jetzt mal ne neues.
Neues Fake. Fake Activation.
Weil ich ja wieder auf meinem
Rechner bin hier.
Telekom. Ja Sibaro. Nice dass du da bist.
Geht alles.
Ähm. So.
Und jetzt brauchen wir http
Util.
Util. Oh wie schreibt man das?
Utility.
Was ist das glaube ich.
Ja.
Und jetzt müssen wir encode.
Url encode machen.
Weil wir wollen das
anhängen hinten dran. Url encode.
Weil im Endeffekt senden wir
ein delete. Eigentlich wäre es besser wenn wir einen post
senden. Fällt mir gerade auf.
Wir machen nicht delete keys.
Wir senden einen post.
Na doch.
Wir belasten es mal
bei delete.
Kann man.
Im delete kann man da im body
was mitschicken geht das?
Probieren wir mal. Habe ich noch nie getestet.
Ich habe noch nie getestet
ob man im delete im body was mitschicken kann.
Ja aber.
Dass man was reinschreiben kann ist klar.
Ich habe keine Ahnung ob der das auswählt.
Stimmt.
Ich habe gestern eine leere collection gesendet.
Ja mal gucken. Mal gucken ob das funktioniert jetzt.
Progress starten.
Warum ist eigentlich
das Programm gesperrt?
Richtig bescheuert
wenn ich das andere starte.
Hm.
Dann machen wir es nämlich nicht mit url encode.
Dann pappen wir das hinten rein.
Wie macht man in eine name value
collection was rein.
Aber dann ist das wieder kompliziert.
Microsoft please.
Bla blub.
Was weiß ich wie das heißt.
So jetzt kann man da jetzt alles rein stecken.
Add.
What?
Okay.
Swing test.
Value mac.
Blub.
So mal gucken ob das im delete jetzt ankommt.
Äh.
Was mache ich da?
Blub nicht add.
So mal gucken ob das im delete jetzt ankommt.
Brauchst noch keys zum testen.
Äh.
Sibaro wenn du nen key hast.
Einen off stream oder so.
Falls du welche hast. Könnten wir schon machen.
Um zu verifizieren das das aktivieren wirklich funktioniert.
Aber brauchen wir nicht unbedingt.
Es können die Jungs auch morgen selbst testen.
Ich meine wir müssen hier keine windows keys
zum Fenster rausschmeißen.
Oh Moment.
Das führen wir jetzt hier garantiert nicht aus.
Das führen wir jetzt garantiert
auf meinem Rechner nicht aus.
Wobei es ist eh kein admin.
Okay.
Ist window activated bla bla.
Gucken wir mal.
Ups.
Hat das jetzt funktioniert?
Ne.
Da müsste es stehen.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Okay.
Upload.
String.
Machen wir es einfach mal so.
Wobei das wird auch nicht funktionieren.
Oh ich habe sie dazu gemacht.
Ich kack grob.
Ich wollte eigentlich das Web Interface noch ein bisschen aufrüsten.
Das kann ja noch gar nichts.
Wollte da noch
Logs rein machen und alles.
Mh mh.
Da müssen wir tatsächlich mal wieder
Stack Overflow zu befragen.
Wobei es könnte auch sein, dass ich
sagen muss.
From body kann auch sein.
Vielleicht so.
Oh ich brauche wieder Windows Key.
1,2,3,4,5
Zack.
Ich brauche Tests.
Okay.
Habe ich denn auch Test genannt?
Ja.
Activate.
Gucken wir mal ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Wow.
Ne kriegt er nicht gebacken.
Der kriegt das nicht gebacken.
Und dann delete mit Sachen drinnen.
Okay wir befragen mal Stack Overflow.
I'm using a delete.
I know.
Okay man darf es anscheinend nicht.
Hm.
Das ist ja blöd.
Ja dann müssen wir es doch in die URL packen.
Delete file.
Ja die parsen sich das irgendwo raus.
Ist ja langweilig.
Ja dann müssen wir.
Dann hängen wir es doch in die URL an.
So wie ich mir das am Anfang gedacht habe.
Also body in
geht nicht.
Na gut.
Wenn das nicht funktioniert.
From.
From query.
Das ist dann quasi Name.
Von dem.
Mac.
Die Mac Adresse von dem Rechner.
Die.
Aktiviert wurde.
Schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert jetzt.
Mac.
Used for.
Okay.
Gucken wir mal ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Also schmeißen wir den Krempel weg.
War wieder leer.
So und dann
URL encoden wir das ganze.
Mac.
Und hängen das in die URL
hinten an.
Das macht es jetzt zwar auch nicht gerade schöner.
Das wir da quasi
noch hinschreiben müssen.
Gleich.
Mac.
Boah sieht das eklig aus jetzt.
Hahaha.
Wie schön ist das.
Ist was anderes.
Want to activate. Yes.
Activating.
Haha.
Guckt mal wir haben eine Mac.
Das funktioniert.
Max verwendet String Interpolation.
Ja das machen wir auch gleich.
So und wenn wir jetzt in die Datenbank
reingucken.
Sollte da auch drinnen stehen.
Used for.
Mac Adresse. Oh das ist cool.
Das ist nice.
Das es funktioniert.
Das ist richtig krass.
Moin Hardware Art.
Ja also ich denke morgen könnt ihr es ausprobieren.
Wir bauen
jetzt noch ein bisschen Schnickschnack ein.
Und wenn das prinzipiell tut bei euch.
Dann mache ich die Keyverwaltung noch ein bisschen schöner.
Weil aktuell ist es einfach
ein Textfeld.
Der
was sich ein bisschen nervig bedienen lässt.
Aber wenn es prinzipiell funktioniert machen wir das
noch
den Wünschen deines Untertans
entsprechend.
Dass man einen Kommentar hinzufügen kann.
Welche Keylieferung das ist.
Gibt es auf Github ja.
Ja ich lade es auf Github noch.
So.
Jetzt machen wir die Logseite.
Weil das wollen wir auf jeden Fall.
Wir haben jetzt so viele Keys und so schon drinnen.
Wir wollen jetzt noch auswerten.
Welche Keys wurden geused.
So deswegen.
Ich will dafür nichts.
Ich will dafür streben.
Wir hätten einfach einen 20 Zeilen PowerShell
machen können.
Und das hier ist die
schönere Variante.
Und außerdem habe ich das ja auch vorgeschlagen.
Dass ich das halt hier im Stream zeigen kann.
Dass ich was kurzes übersichtliches habe.
Wo man halt.
Weißt du. Nichts wo irgendwie wieder Monate dauert.
Sondern was wo ich einfach mal in 1, 2, 3 Tagen
fertig machen kann.
Mit Nvidia.
Hast du mit Nvidia irgendwas laufen?
Ich habe ja mit denen früher auch ein paar Sachen gemacht.
Falls ja würde mich interessieren.
Kannst du mir mal privat schreiben.
Wer dort dein Kontakt ist.
So.
Genau.
Wir wollten jetzt noch die Logs einbauen.
Weil das ist eigentlich so das Feature was das auch ein bisschen abhebt.
Vom Rest.
Achso.
Ich dachte jetzt für Youtube du hast irgendwie
mit irgendeinem Community Manager oder mit sonst was Kontakt.
Weil ich wollte einfach mal wissen ob noch die gleichen Leute da sind.
Die ich auch noch kenne.
Okay wir machen jetzt einen neuen Controller.
So und das geht jetzt schnell.
Aber das wird ganz nice.
Neuer Controller.
Das ist der Log Controller.
So.
Und der Log Controller.
Der hat
Controller.
Base.
Ich kann immer noch nicht richtig tippen.
Controller Base.
Constructor.
Kriegen wir dann ab DB Context.
Context.
Ups.
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Geh weg.
Ähm.
Also der digitale Nickname ist Model.
Da brauchen wir jetzt eigentlich nur genau
eine Methode.
Und zwar die Main-Geschichte.
Das wird ein http get.
public.
I'm unarbreable.
Windows License.
Get Logs.
Ups.
Return.
Context.
License.
Und jetzt kommt der Gag daran.
Nur die License, die benutzt werden, wollen wir in die Logs schreiben.
So, dann brauchen wir jetzt noch hier einmal kopieren.
Rename Logs.
Active.
So, dann machen wir jetzt eine schöne Tabelle rein.
Also die GetKey-Methode müssen wir ein bisschen ändern.
Und zwar, wir wollen nicht ApiKey, wir wollen ApiLogs holen.
JSON-Response-Key. Bin ich in der richtigen Datei? Ja.
Des Keys.
Die ganzen anderen Krempel können wir rausschmeißen.
So, Keys. Jetzt haben wir uns die Keys gegettet.
Wollen wir mal starten.
Ich habe eine Sache vergessen. Wartet kurz.
Ich habe vergessen, beim Controller dabei zu schreiben, unter welcher Adresse er verfügbar sein soll.
Logs.
Das wird jetzt ganz nice gleich.
So.
Okay, die Form brauchen wir nicht mehr.
Dann machen wir jetzt eine Tabelle.
Table.
Also, Table, was brauchen wir denn da?
Key.
Datum oder sowas. Wie nennt man das?
Used.
Da kann man sich glaube ich was schönes ausdenken.
Und irgendwie Mac.
Okay.
So.
Und jetzt brauchen wir einfach eine Vorschleife.
Wie vor in Keys.
Und dann sagen wir Table.
Und da soll jetzt reinkommen...
Warum schreibe ich eigentlich immer Keys?
Keys ist doof. Das Ding heißt ja nicht...
Das sind ja eigentlich viel mehr als Keys.
Wir nennen es...
Eigentlich sind es ja Lizenzen. Da steht ja noch viel mehr dabei.
Ja.
Also eigentlich wollen wir sowas wie...
License in...
Ja, ich klicke auch schöner.
Licenses.
License.
Key.
Aha.
Sehr schön.
License Key.
Dann wollen wir haben...
Used.
Add.
Und wir wollen haben...
Die...
Used.
Vor.
So.
Und jetzt müssen wir die Tabelle noch ein bisschen ordentlich formatieren.
Weil so sieht das scheiße aus.
Aber das ist doch nice.
Da kann man nachgucken.
Ich copy-paste mir jetzt einfach was.
Äh... Styles.
Ich copy-paste mir hier mal was aus ähm...
einer anderen Seite.
Wo hab ich denn...
Hier.
Copy-paste.
Ah.
Das sieht doch schon mal viel besser aus, oder?
Das sieht doch schon mal ganz nice aus.
Jetzt siehst du hier quasi, welcher Windows-Key wann eingelöst wurde und von welcher Mac.
Jetzt brauchen wir bloß noch was, was das Datum ordentlich formatiert.
Irgendwie sowas.
Date.
Time.
So.
Und jetzt kommt ein bisschen JavaScript-Magic.
Hm.
Also.
Format.
Date.
Time.
Da schieben wir den .NET DateTime rein.
Und der .NET DateTime sind gepasst in JavaScript Millisekunden seit 1970.
Weil.
Warum es ausgerechnet Millisekunden seit 1970 sind, keine Ahnung.
Weil irgendjemand Spaß daran hat, komische Formate sich auszudenken.
Ah.
Jetzt haben wir hier das Datum drin.
Und jetzt können wir das Datum formatieren.
Und zwar.
Können wir sagen.
Äh.
Return.
DateToLocal.
DateString.
Und dann können wir sagen, wir wollen es auf jeden Fall im deutschen Format haben.
Guck.
Jetzt sieht das Ganze aber auch viel schöner aus schon.
Oh.
Ich habe das falsche genommen.
Ich habe die Mac-Adresse versucht als DateTime zu parsen.
Na gut.
Kann ja mal passieren.
Ja.
So ist das schon besser, oder?
Ich weiß, dass das Unix-Time ist.
Aber warum möchte man bitteschön in JavaScript DateTime standardmäßig als Millisekunden seit
1970 haben?
Sollen sie Now nehmen oder so?
Das ist doch cool, oder?
Hier hat man die Keys.
Hier passen.
Wir passen jetzt würde ich sagen hier auch nochmal TextBox.
TextArea.
Ah, wie haben wir dafür noch gar nichts angelegt.
Okay.
Da gruppiere ich mir das nämlich von.
Auch einfach von hier.
Lul.
Einfach ein, ein nices.
Copy-Paste.
Ha!
Das ist doch schick.
Das gefällt mir.
Hier hast du deine Keys drinnen.
Hier hast du Logs drinnen.
So.
Ich hab erst mal den Stream abgekackt mit der Musik.
Ja.
Das ist auch ganz nice.
So, und hier hast du dann die Übersicht.
Man muss die Übersicht natürlich auch ein bisschen
beschneiden, zum Beispiel, dass man sagt,
ähm,
ja, das, äh, Hardware-Rad,
das hat der, ähm,
Moment, ich sag's dir gleich,
der
Gabi Ralli schon erzählt.
Das baue ich ein, nachdem ihr es ausprobiert habt.
Weil aktuell
ist es, ähm, relativ
billig. Es ist einfach ein Textfeld, wo Keys
reinkommen. Da müssen wir das nämlich ein bisschen
aufsplitten. Dann machen wir
hier kein Textfeld, wo die Keys reinkommen.
Dann machen wir hier einen Hinzufügen-Knopf.
Dann geht das Textfeld auf.
Dann kannst du die Keys reinpasten und oben
noch ein Kommentar drüber.
Das geht jetzt so grad nicht. Das, das
mache ich dann, nachdem ihr es ausprobiert habt.
Nachdem ihr es ausprobiert habt,
machen wir das dann auch mit dem, mit, ähm,
ihr könnt's ja morgen einfach mal mit zwei Keys
oder so ausprobieren, ob sich das Aktivieren prinzipiell
funktioniert.
Aber jetzt locken wir uns irgendwie ins Discord oder so noch dabei
und du guckst einfach mal, ob's geht.
Ähm, weil wie gesagt, ich konnte alles
testen, hier jetzt außer halt eben das Aktivieren
selbst. Und wenn das
alles geht und alles drin ist,
was du brauchst, ähm,
dann gucken wir, ob wir es irgendwie als Docker-Container
für dann nass basteln.
Wie hast du denn das Aktivieren implementiert?
Der, das ist,
das ist eine Konsolenanwendung, die
kommt halt auf den Server, auf den, auf den Client
drauf. Und die schickt,
die holt sich den, die holt sich einen Key
vom Server und nachdem das Aktivieren
erfolgreich war, hier, guck,
da, wenn das
Aktivieren erfolgreich war,
dann, ähm, sagt sie dem Server, hier,
markiere mal diesen Key als, ähm,
benutzt.
Und dann nimmt der Server den raus.
Ich, mir ist übrigens grad
eine Idee gekommen, wie wir das noch viel besser machen können.
Wir benutzen
einfach bei KeyController,
wir benutzen kein Delete,
wir benutzen kein Delete, sondern wir benutzen
ein Put,
weil Put ist eigentlich
das Restswort, das Schlüsselwort
für, ähm,
Item ändern.
Warte.
Was hat der denn hier für Schmerzen, ah.
Das ist eigentlich viel besser.
Weil jetzt können wir die Mac auch so
als, als String übergeben, glaube ich.
Hoffe ich.
Die Log-Seiten noch mit einer Seitenfunktion ausstatten.
Ja, das machen wir.
Warte mal, das ist alles noch so Feintuning.
Ich will halt so die Basisfunktion
alle reinkriegen.
Ich hätte zum Beispiel gerne noch mal
so ein Beispiel-Graf auf der,
auf der Statistik-Seite,
sowas wie, ähm,
heute aktiviert pro Stunde oder sowas
machen wir da einfach rein.
Bitte noch Hard-Coded-Server-IP denken,
mach ich alles noch.
Wie gesagt, ich schicke euch das ja eh erst morgen,
ähm,
wenn ich wach bin dann.
Und dann können wir ja mal gucken.
Oh, jetzt haben wir hier die Mac,
jetzt sollen wir das mit dem Put machen, ist glaube ich
besser.
Put, äh, Put.
Was haben wir denn eigentlich alles zur Auswahl?
Upload, Upload Values, Upload Data, Upload File, Upload String.
Okay, Upload Values klingt irgendwie am sinnigsten.
Upload Values.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt doch wieder den gleichen, ja,
Bloop.
Add, Add.
Mac, Mac.
So, jetzt funktioniert es hoffentlich.
Äh, Key-Controller.
Jetzt ist es ein Put, bin ich mal gespannt, ob das jetzt klappt.
Bei, bei Context denkst du, äh, bei CTX
denkst du an Citrix, nicht an Context.
Ich hab mir das angewöhnt, ich schreib das überall, Context mit CTX,
aber das ist schon, kann ich verstehen,
das ist Geschmackssache.
Okay, ähm,
ausführen.
Activate, bla bla bla.
Wartet mal kurz.
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert hat.
Immer noch nicht.
Warum?
Alter, wo hat er denn jetzt damit Probleme, bitteschön?
Wo hat er denn damit jetzt Probleme?
Warum geht denn der Kram jetzt hier an der Stelle nicht?
Mac.
Wollen wir so vielleicht mal ausprobieren.
Ich hab Systemintegration gelernt vor über 10 Jahren.
Hat er jetzt überhaupt was gemacht?
Okay, was genau hat er denn jetzt für Schmerzen?
Ja.
auch from body wie macht man das denn jetzt richtig put wie schicke ich das denn jetzt
upload webclient update produkt async okay put as jason async okay wir machen jetzt was anderes
wir rufen das jetzt wir rufen das jetzt von wir rufen das jetzt mal mit irgendeinem ordentlichen
tool auch wo man gucken kann was passiert wir speichern wir speichern das ganze auch
nicht kann das sein dass man kann das sein dass das hier zuerst kommen muss so was hier
sondern jetzt gucken wir uns das mal an habe ich hier post man drauf post man ein dann installieren
wir das jetzt mal bestes tool für irgendwelche rest apis zum ausprobieren was da so passiert
da kann man das nämlich mal ordentlich debuggen dann weiß ich
auch was mit meinem kleinen dahin schicken muss moin offiziell limitix weißt du wisst ihr was
richtig richtig cool finde auf twitch das wichtigste ist und wie gesagt ich habe im
vergleich zu wirklich großen jetzt nicht viele zuschauer ja aber was ich gemerkt habe was das
wichtigste auf twitch ist dass man zuschauer bekommt und zuschauer hält es ist natürlich
schon von vorteil wenn man auf youtube schon gewisse größer hat keine frage das wichtigste
ist und das kann ich euch jetzt mal zeigen ich habe hier auf youtube schon gewisse größe hat keine frage das wichtigste ist und das
kannst du echt universal auf twitch sagen ist regelmäßig streamenna
regelmäßig streamen das ist einfach so krass wie ich bin der unterschied zwischen ich habe ein
paar wochen nicht gestreamt und streamen wieder zu ich stream alle paar tage ich
stream ich kann aber ich habe vier fünf wochen nicht gestreamt ich hab 80 zuschauer ich deswegen
ein paar tage am stück die leute kriegen es wieder mit 160 werden heute zweihundert das ist bei einem
sinnlosen programmiert streamen
PUTT
Okay, PUT, PUT, meine Adresse ist, ja, http, 164.api.ts.1 oder, weiß ich nicht, SQL-Browser, was ist denn die verfügbare, oh, wir haben schon ein paar IDs eingefügt.
Ähm, Aldi 9690, could not get response, warum, kommt nichts an, warum, wo ist das Problem, ah, ich habe mich verschrieben, aha, was, war doch meine API, oder, ah, PORT, ich kann ja mal denken, äh, jetzt, so, und da kann man jetzt reinschreiben,
Body.
Kann man nicht JSON oder so machen, JSON, Text, so, ähm, äh, so fast, ich suche, ich weiß nicht, was du da für Dinger postest, aber das hat nichts hier mit dem Stream zu tun, ähm, Sibaro, mach mal weg, ich weiß nicht, was es ist, aber ich habe hier so ein Browser-Plugin, was mir eine Vorschau anzeigt, es sind irgendwelche, irgendwelche Pastebin-Gedöns.
Ich verkürze meine Vorschau.
Vorschau reloaden, okay, ähm, so, jetzt gucken wir mal, dass wir den Parameters, probieren wir es mal da drüber, das müsste ja direkt funktionieren, also, wenn wir sagen, hier, Mac ist, ist, blub, blub, send, Mac ist, blub, blub, blub, funktioniert, und das ist, wenn es in der URL drin ist, ups, äh, Body, äh, äh, Parameter, Body, Raw, ja, Text, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das richtig schreibt, aber, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh,
blub, blub, send, okay, funktioniert so nicht, äh, wie sieht, wie sieht das eigentlich richtig aus, ich hab gar keine Ahnung, wie man, wie schreibt man das richtig in Body rein, ähm, äh, ah, so, äh, usually content type ist, äh, blablabla, www, encoded, okay, und dann sagt man, Mac, gleich, blub, blub, funktioniert aber nicht,
äh, funktioniert nicht, weil da nicht from body dran steht, machen wir das mal, from body, wollen wir mal rauskriegen, wie der Camping funktioniert, also übrigens, wenn ihr mal Rest-APs und Gedöns debuggen müsst, kann ich euch nur diesen, den Postman echt nur empfehlen, das ist echt praktisch, kann man sich alles angucken, äh, hallo, hat das jetzt, input was not valid, warum, warum ist mein input not valid, das, das war ursprünglich eine Browser-Erweiterung,
hier, das ist die, bloß das, äh, Chrome, ja, sagt, sie unterstützen keine Error-AP mehr, Alter, wo ist denn jetzt mein, wo ist denn jetzt das Problem dabei, kann ich irgendwie sagen, content type oder so, oh man, wo ist denn das Problem jetzt hier, na, das mach ich dann falsch, from body, okay, gut, nice, ups, oh man, ich kann nicht mehr nachdenken, pack mich voll ab, geht das nicht, so,
also, Mac, bla bla bla, send, macht er nicht, nix drin, auch nix drin, ich bin grad echt überfragt, wie ich denn, das kann doch nicht so kompliziert sein, ich mein, mit dem Post funktioniert es doch auch, mit dem Post funktioniert es doch auch, äh, ich check echt nicht, wo das Problem ist, er sagt ja auch, will, will, will encoded, Moment, ich hab ne Idee, wir brauchen nicht, haha, wartet mal, wir brauchen nicht from body, wir brauchen,
from form,
wahrscheinlich einfach nur, ha, haha, warum immer, from form geht, from form ist okay, from form funktioniert, nice, okay, dann wissen wir jetzt, was wir machen müssen, so, dann gucken wir erstmal, ob der Upload funktioniert, mit dem Korgastool, gucken wir, ob das jetzt klappt, ja, funktioniert, okay,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen müssen wir from form nehmen, anstatt from body, ich hab keine Ahnung, warum, ist mir aber auch scheißegal, funktioniert, vollkommen egal, okay, ähm, das tut, da sind die ganzen, ganzen Weeb-E-Mails am Start im Chat, okay, gut, funktioniert, so, was machen wir denn als nächstes, was haben wir denn hier schönes, noch offen, Logs, Stats,
dass wir hier noch Kommentare dazu schreiben können, hab ich mir aufgeschrieben, das machen wir, nachdem der Test erfolgreich war, wollen wir noch, wollen wir jetzt mal richtig, richtig, ähm, advanced sein und unter Stats, wollen wir unter Stats noch einen Graph einbinden, der anzeigt, wie viel Keys pro Stunde aktiviert wurden, komm, das machen wir noch, oder, da haben wir noch ein bisschen Eye-Candy dabei, kann man einbauen, dass sich die kleinen Echsen an erfolgreicher Aktivierung selbst löschen, ja, ich schreib's mir mal auf,
okay, wobei ich mir eher gedacht hab, wobei ich mir eher gedacht hab, die kleinen Echse sollte sich nicht selbst löschen, sondern, die sollte ein Custom-Script von euch ausführen, indem ihr dann unter anderem die Echse löschen könnt, weil dann könntet ihr danach noch x-beliebige Sachen ausführen lassen, im Prinzip könntet ihr alles ausführen lassen, was ihr halt in ein Power-Shield-Script reinschreiben könnt, okay, haben wir jetzt irgendwas Essentielles, was ich noch, äh, vergessen hab,
okay,
nach der Aktivierung
ist die Echse
die Echse,
und dann ist der PC fertig,
ja, vielleicht wollt ihr ja Sachen machen, also hat Werreiter gestern gemeint, irgendwie sowas, wie ihr wollt ein Script haben, was euch quasi unverwendete Festplatten formatiert und sowas,
das müsst ihr natürlich selber machen, aber das könnte man ausführen lassen, automatisch, da muss man das nicht jedes Mal von Hand machen,
also auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, wenn das Ding ein Custom-Script ausführen kann,
ne, die Echse ist nicht auf dem USB-Stick, die Echse ist im Installer drin,
ne, das ist nicht das aktuelle Projekt, das ist nur so, genau, das ist nur eingeschoben, wie das Ebaro schreibt,
so, das heißt, wir machen jetzt noch einen,
kopieren wir den Kramer,
aus dem Key-Controller
wird ein
Stat-Controller
für Statistik,
das Copy-Paste ich mir aber aus anderen Sachen, die ich schon hab, zusammen jetzt,
ähm,
Stat-Controller,
ne, Stat-Controller,
Stat,
so,
und,
der braucht im End-Effekt,
nur einen Get,
nur einen Get, allerdings mit Custom-Url,
ein Get auf, ähm,
Today,
da gibt's dann quasi jetzt schön kopiert die Sachen, die heutzutage, die heute eingelöst wurden,
so, und wie kriegen wir die Sachen raus, die heute eingelöst wurden?
Und zwar, würde ich sagen, erstmal brauchen wir Today,
Today ist Date-Time, jetzt kommt Trick 17,
äh, ist auch ne coole Sache,
also, könnte, könnte nützlich sein für Leute, die sich schadprogrammieren,
Date-Time-Now kennt wahrscheinlich jeder,
aber wenn man sagt Date-Time-Now.date,
also, von dem aktuellen Date-Time-Objekt,
mit Date kriegt man quasi nur die
Datums-Portion raus, und alles andere ist auf 0 gesetzt,
das heißt, ich bekomme jetzt nen Date-Time raus, heute,
um 0 Uhr,
was ich gut vergleichen kann mit den Zeitstempeln hier drinnen.
Weil jetzt will ich quasi alle License-Keys haben,
die, ähm,
used sind,
die used sind,
und,
ähm,
used at größer ist,
als today.
Das heißt, im Prinzip alle,
bei so ner einfachen Abfrage geht das, ähm,
also, im Prinzip alles, was heute aktiviert wurde.
So, und jetzt müssen wir das noch groupen,
group by, ähm,
ah, ist der Stream abgeschissen?
Nutzt du auf deinem Server Linux oder Windows?
Linux. Auf dem Server würde ich nie Windows installieren.
group by, ähm, date-time,
ähm, used at,
äh, used at,
was war das für ein Schmerz, ne?
Achso, ja, das ist klar, das ist nicht funktioniert.
Ähm, group by used at Stunde.
ähm, group by used at Stunde.
Ja, und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt,
bekommen wir da sowas hier raus, im Endeffekt.
Ja, und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, bekommen wir da sowas hier raus, im Endeffekt.
Ja, und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, just click here.
Jetzt kriegen wir quasi ein Objekt raus, was hier drinne stehen hat.
Äh, Stunde,
keine Ahnung, Stunde, aktuelle Stunde ist 18,
und in 18 wurden so und so viele keys aktiviert.
Bla, bla, bla.
In 19 so und so viele keys und sowas,
haben wir da jetzt drinne stehen.
Ähm, select,
machen wir mal einen Zeitumbruch hin.
Ich kann mich immer nicht entscheiden, ob Punkt vor
oder Punkt nach, ja.
select group by, ähm, group by used at time.
key
achso, wir müssen uns jetzt irgendwas überlegen
was wir da returnen können, key value pair
ist wahrscheinlich das einfachste
key value pair aus
Stunde
und Anzahl
ja
new key value pair
Stunde
und
Anzahl
müsste das jetzt, müsste so passen
hoffe ich
das heißt, wenn ich jetzt quasi hier anfrage
api stats, probieren wir das doch mal mit postman
gleich aus
gucken wir mal, was wir da zurückkriegen
postman
und zwar diesmal wollen wir haben
api keys
api stats
today
und einfach nur den get
ja
ist doch nice, guckt mal
um 15 Uhr
also in
in der Stunde, 15 Uhr
haben wir 2 keys aktiviert
16 Uhr 6 keys
17 Uhr 4 keys
can you help me
with furia
analysis, no
I can't
so, jetzt kriegen wir dann
ordentliches array zurück
wobei es kein array mit javascript objekten drin
und da könnte man jetzt einfach
einen graft rausbauen
ich würde sagen, wir machen
so ein
so ein balkendiagramm oder so
oder was meint ihr?
wir gucken mal, also wir werden das hier vernennen
das, es gibt
gott um die welt
hunderttausende javascript
graftbibliotheken, die einzige mit der ich bisher was gemacht habe
ist die hier
und die ist auch echt ganz nice, die gibt es auch noch für python
und ich glaube
java
ist gar nicht für was es die alles gibt
products
ach keine ahnung
zumindest
was nehmen wir dafür
ich würde ja sagen so einen
so einen balken
so ein balkendiagramm ist eigentlich am schönsten
einfach so ein
so ein balkendiagramm so nach dem motto
keine ahnung
15 Uhr, 16 Uhr, 17 Uhr
oder
sowas in der Richtung würde ich sagen
weil die alle
anderen diagrammtypen sehen viel zu abgedreht aus
weil ich meine ich brauche keinen
2D density plot
wenn ich einfach anzeigen lassen will
wieviel keys in der stelle eingelöst wurden
ok
stats
also
passen wir das hier mal an
slash stats habe ich schon gemacht
ob die seite jetzt am start ist
stats
ja funktioniert
ok
stats
active
ok das ding kommt weg
da bleibt jetzt nur noch ein div übrig
das div kriegt die id char
das werden wir uns zusammen copy pasten
klar
was hast du für ein linux auf deinem
ubuntu
ubuntu beste
ich bin fan von ubuntu server
weiß gar nicht warum das immer so
schlecht geredet wird
ich find viel angenehmer
zu benutzen als sagen wir mal redhat oder sowas
auf dem desktop
mag ich dafür kein ubuntu ich find's ja witzig
die meisten leute verbinden mit ubuntu
ein desktop betriebssystem ich verwende es auf dem desktop nicht
da verwende ich nur mal jarro
das ist so ein archlinux
abkömmling
und auf dem server verwende ich da
ubuntu wo quasi alle anderen
irgendwie
redhat oder suse oder
was sind denn noch schöne server
debian verwenden
nämlich ubuntu
redhat läuft auf ubuntu ja die jungs wissen ja auch was sie machen
redhat server ist wunderbar
äh nicht redhat server ubuntu server ist ganz toll
aktuellere pakete
spricht dafür bei ubuntu
ein paar entscheidungen von ubuntu sind fragwürdig
ja wie diese komische yaml netzwerk config
die braucht kein mensch
aber alles in allem
ist ubuntu die server distribution
die mich am wenigsten nervt
ansonsten für alle debian fans
ist halt auch nicht viel unterschied
so in basic sachen dazwischen
so ähm
charts
ok ähm
also
wie machen wir das denn jetzt
mit der mit dem
mit der grafik
als erstes müssen wir erstmal plotly
einbinden
fangen wir mal vor
plotly
den krempeln machen wir wieder weg den brauchen wir hier nicht
so
eigentlich brauchen wir hier gar nichts großartiges
wir brauchen ja auch den kram nicht
können wir mal weg machen
komplett
wir müssen eigentlich nur
und data
ja data brauchen wir sowas wie licenses today
vielleicht lassen wir das mal
das get keys doch da
get keys licenses
äh genau
also wir fetchen
wir fetchen jetzt stats
und da kriegen wir
den jason zurück mit unserem geschwubbel drinnen
und da speichern wir
licenses today
today
speichern wir das drinnen
so kann man
kann man eigentlich mounted async machen
probieren wir mal aus
await
so und jetzt
mus wir da unser plotly
da aber das copy past ich mir vor was andere was ich hier habe
rein also
ohbei das ist eigentlich ziemlich übersichtlich
also wir brauchen
ein datafeld
mit ähm
folgenden sachen drinnen
y graph
ist keine ahnung erstmal null
x graph ist auch erstmal null
ja
Ein Array aus Null.
So, und dann muss man auch sagen, Type.
Und dann hier Balkendiagramm.
Und jetzt kommt Plotly New Plot Chart Data.
Das war's.
Mehr brauchen wir eigentlich für so einen billigen Graph erstmal gar nicht.
Da wird natürlich jetzt nichts drin sein, aber es wird ein Graph anzeigen, hoffe ich.
Äh, nein, warum nicht?
Äh, äh, habe ich irgendwo was vergessen?
Syntaxfehler?
Ah, hier.
Ne.
Wo habe ich einen Syntaxfehler produziert, Leute?
Falsche Uhr?
Nö, wohl ist richtig.
Ah!
Ah, weißt du, wenn man so lange davor sitzt, da sieht man es nicht.
Ah, jetzt haben wir auch.
Jetzt haben wir schon einen krassen Graph am Start.
Der zwar noch nichts macht, der aber grapht schon mal rum.
So, der kriegt jetzt noch ein paar Optionen mit.
Und zwar, Title nennen wir sowas wie Aktivierte Rechner heute.
Irgendwie so.
Ah.
Das Programm ist echt eine wilde Mischung aus Deutsch und Englisch.
So, jetzt haben wir Höhe.
250.
Ganz so hoch muss das Ding ja nicht sein.
Ups.
Ja.
Nice.
So, und jetzt müssen wir noch sagen.
Boah, eigentlich müssen wir gar nichts mehr machen, oder?
Das sieht doch ganz okay aus.
Dann füllen wir jetzt einfach mal unsere Daten rein und mal gucken, wie das Ganze aussieht.
Ach ja doch, ich sehe hier bei meinem anderen Projekt noch eine Sache.
Die kann ich mir jetzt copy-pasten.
die man noch machen muss, dass es besser aussieht, ist das hier.
Da kommt nämlich kein komisches Overlay hier.
So, jetzt haben wir unsere Keys und jetzt können wir uns quasi rausholen,
also für die Y-Achse, Y-Licenses-Today-Map-License
und da wollen wir jetzt einfach nur rausholen,
den Wert, wie viele Lizenzen aktiviert wurden.
Aha!
Ich meine, die X-Achse stimmt noch nicht, aber prinzipiell ist es schon mal ganz gut.
So, und X, da brauchen wir jetzt ein bisschen mehr.
So, und da wollen wir sagen, License,
und da brauchen wir jetzt entweder...
Datum, also das Aktuelle,
und wir resetten alles,
das kann man da machen, bis auf die Stunde.
Und die Stunde ist Key, das wissen wir ja.
Das haben wir hier reingeschrieben, das.
In Key die Stunde, wann das Ganze angelegt wurde.
So, Minute 0, Dings 0, alles 0, zack.
Return Date.
Nice, guck mal.
Und zack, haben wir einen Graph, wie was aktiviert wurde.
Das ist doch mega-Poggers, oder?
Jetzt haben wir hier nochmal Width, irgendwie 600.
Das ist doch cool.
Das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Aber ich finde nicht, ich finde, das hat was.
Das hier sieht auch ein bisschen gestaucht aus, ne?
Ah, ich habe noch was vergessen, das Copy-Paste-Team auch nochmal.
Ah, ich habe hier noch was.
Gucken wir mal, ob das was bringt.
Das ändert nichts, oder?
Ist es nicht ein wenig auferkehrt, für so eine simple Seite, View anzuziehen?
Doch.
Aber wir haben genug Rechenleistung.
Wir haben genug Rechenleistung.
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz hübsch so.
Ah, jetzt haben wir die Keyverwaltung, jetzt haben wir ein paar Logs,
und wir haben noch, wie viele Sachen die Stunde aktiviert wurden.
Das ist doch cool.
Kann man vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner machen,
das kann dazwischen dritter mal angezeigt werden.
Ja, so ist nice.
Nice, oder?
Was würde passieren, wenn man jetzt JavaScript im Browser macht?
Du siehst keinen Inhalt mehr.
Du siehst ein leeres Textfeld,
du siehst eine leere Tabelle,
und du siehst eine leere Seite.
Das würde passieren, wenn du JavaScript ausmachst.
Aber das ist doch schick, oder?
Ich meine, das ist ein bisschen overkill,
das braucht wahrscheinlich kein Mensch,
aber ich finde, das ist irgendwie nice, ne?
Ja.
Irgendwie gefällt mir das.
Wenn man noch ein bisschen gucken muss,
das hier sieht nicht sonderlich konsistent zu dem da aus, ne?
Kann das sein, dass die Hintergrundfarbe hier komplett anders ist als bei dem?
Das müssen wir noch ändern.
Textarea,
Read Only,
das haben wir schon.
Oder haben wir Disabled gesetzt und nicht Read Only?
Muss ich mal kurz schauen.
Ah, Disabled haben wir gesetzt.
Disabled brauchen wir eigentlich.
Das sieht schon viel besser aus.
Border Radius 50%.
Ist 50% nicht so?
Ja, da ist er.
Der zieht mir besonders viel noch.
Aber wir können ja die Textboxen ein bisschen abgerundet machen.
Wie kann man eigentlich das Resize ausschalten?
Von der Textarea.
Okay, das geht anscheinend nur mit CSS.
Auch gut.
Das ist doch hübsch.
Das gefällt mir jetzt echt gut.
Das geht mit der Musik ab.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Moin Juli Geneticus.
Ich finde das sehr nice.
Irgendwie hat das was, oder?
Hier kann man noch mehr Statistiken reinmachen.
Aber das ist ja nur wirklich Spielerei gerade.
Da könnt ihr sehen,
Da könnt ihr sehen, wo ihr die meisten Rechner aktiviert habt.
In History machen wir noch Paging und so.
Aber morgen wird erstmal getestet, ob das prinzipiell funktioniert.
Und jetzt alles zentriert.
Könnten wir machen, wenn das alles so auf der Seite hängt.
Sieht kacke aus.
Ding-Sound.
Ernsthaft?
Wollt ihr nen blöden Sound abgespielt haben,
wenn das Ding fertig ist, wenn ihr was aktiviert habt?
Kann ich euch einbauen, das ist kein großer...
Bitte kein Sound, ist doch affig.
Ja, man könnte nen Ding-Sound machen, sobald ein Key aktiviert wurde.
Ja, der Browser soll nicht Bing machen.
Der Server soll Bing machen, das ist klar.
Please sweep, TTS.
Nein, das baue ich da nicht ein.
Ich wollte das noch zentrieren, alles.
Kann man eigentlich einfach sagen,
Geht das?
Kann ich jetzt sagen, Body,
Allein,
Ne, wie geht denn das?
Text-Align, Center,
Geht das? Und ist jetzt alles zentriert?
Passt.
Wie kriege ich denn den Mist auch noch zentriert hier?
Was?
Margin-Auto?
Ne, what? Wie? Wo?
Achso, warte mal, ich setze das Zeug ja hier explizit auf Left.
Ja, aber jetzt ist es untereinander, das ist auch dumm.
Oh, ich hab mit CSS echt, bin ich nicht so der geile CSS-Owner.
Ich find's auch so zentriert, ehrlich gesagt, ist gar nicht mal so geil.
Der Edit-Button darf ein bisschen größer sein, vor allem.
Nicht Windows.
Margin von links ein bisschen, ja.
Ja, bisschen viel, hä?
Und oben können wir auch ein bisschen Margin machen.
Zehn Pixels oder so.
Ja, das ist doch ganz hübsch.
Das ist doch ganz hübsch jetzt.
Tabelle machen wir auch Border-Radius.
Zwei.
Geht das nicht?
Kann man keine abgerundeten Tabellen machen?
Mit CSS? Kann das sein, dass das nicht funktioniert?
Achso, vielleicht sollte ich noch
eine Farbe angeben.
Was ist die schwarzen Linien, Mac? Tu mal ins T hier.
Wo hab ich denn denn die da?
Ne. Hä?
Wo hab ich denn?
Ja, das sieht besser aus.
So? Meint ihr so ist besser?
Okay.
Den Header zentrieren.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Eigentlich, wir wollen nur den Header zentrieren.
Nur.
Warum genau hat er das jetzt nicht zentriert?
Achso, weil ich gar keinen Header verwendet hab.
Wie geht denn das nochmal mit Table-Header?
Oh, geil.
Also, das Struggle.
TH
muss ich machen oben.
Wobei, ob das zentriert so viel besser aussieht?
Na, ich find's schon
schicker.
Ach, das war's? Nicht wirklich.
Ja, aber so kann das bleiben.
Da müssen wir jetzt noch eine Überschrift hinmachen.
Big Font.
Big Shack.
Kommen wir jetzt noch hier. Kommt noch hin.
Unter das Navigationsding.
A3.
Hat eigentlich Big Shack was Neues.
Was mach ich da eigentlich?
Ich brauch ja da gar nichts mehr dazwischen, oder?
The Tingoes.
Genau, Quick Maths.
So war am besten.
Unbenutzte
Keys.
Unbenutzte Keys.
So, dann gibt's jetzt noch hier eine Überschrift auf der anderen Seite.
Nicht unbenutzte Keys.
Statistiken.
So, und bei
Logs. Äh.
History.
Mir fällt jetzt grad nichts anderes ein.
Ist doch echt ganz schick geworden.
Jetzt noch Windows 10 VM.
Was meinst du, was ich hier hab?
Problem ist, dass ich keinen Key hab zum Aktivieren.
Ja, wir haben's ja schon ausprobiert.
Es geht außer das Aktivieren.
Geht alles. Auch im Fehlerfall
macht er den Key nicht weg.
Aber mir gefällt das jetzt echt ganz gut.
Wir machen jetzt noch, ähm.
Vielleicht sollten wir
das hier.
Logs.
Stats.
Das binden wir dann alles nochmal über eine gemeinsame
Seite drum herum ein.
Also ist das ein bisschen eklig, wenn man das alles immer
copy-pasten muss.
Achso. Oh, ich noob.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der Button damit gut aussieht.
Der ist dann einfach rund.
Irgendwie finde ich das echt cool.
Das gefällt mir.
Die zwei Seiten sehen ja konsistent aus.
Die Textbox gefällt mir noch nicht so gut.
Hast du mir Windows 10 Key geschickt?
Ja, das kann ich aber nicht on-stream machen.
Da ist der Key. Ratzfatz weg.
Aber Leute, ich muss jetzt auch
gleich mal was vortragen. Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Hier kann man dann später noch
andere Statistiken reinmachen, die einem
was bringen.
Ich finde das echt cool.
Mir gefällt das jetzt.
Ich kann da jetzt eine Weile durchklicken.
Irgendwie hat das was.
Gefällt mir echt gut.
Was ich mag ist, dass die
Webseite ist super simpel.
Das, was ich bei den meisten Webseiten
so vermisse. Du hast zigtausend
Dinger, was dir auf den Sack geht.
Und hier ist im Prinzip nichts drinnen,
außer das, was du sehen willst.
Du hast ein Textfeld mit Keys,
wo du Keys reinpasten kannst.
Und er halt nur die Keys speichert,
die nicht doppelt sind.
Du hast History von Keys,
die aktiviert wurden. Und wann?
Aber View.
Naja komm, der View-Teil ist nur wirklich
simpel überall.
Hätten wir einen ordentlichen
Build-Step, so mit irgendwie
Webpack oder so.
Könnten wir auch ordentlich View-Komponenten
verwenden und müssten nicht quasi auf jeder
Seite View neu einbinden.
Anti-Adblock, das Ding läuft intern.
Da ist es vollkommen egal.
Mach doch eine Animation für den
Tab-Wechsel rein. Könnte man machen.
Könnte man machen.
Zeig mal, was hat uns denn der Sebaro
da für ein Code-Pen geschickt?
Ach, die Uhrzeit! WTF,
die habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Ja klar, die Uhrzeit muss da auch noch
rein. Klar muss die da auch
noch rein.
To Local Timestring.
Oh,
Uhrzeit. Ja, ja, ist schon mal
klein besser, ey.
Was willst du nur mit dem Datum, ja.
So, was hat uns der Sebaro hier geschickt?
Oh!
Oh, das sieht natürlich richtig
brau aus, ne?
Aber schon wieder übelst lahm, guck mal.
Kommt gar nicht hinterher mit dem Klicken.
Aber die Transition hier unten finde ich ganz
cool. Wie macht der denn das?
Das ist jQuery, ne?
Wie macht
der denn hier unten die Transition zwischen den
...
... das Überblenden, wie macht der denn das?
Was? Guck dir das mal bitte an.
Kann ich das einfach so aufmachen,
ohne ... aber ich sehe, das ist ein Overwatch-Clip,
mehr sehe ich in der Vorschau nicht.
Oh, ein Exklusiv-Clip,
da muss ich leiser machen.
Ja, der geht schon ab teilweise.
Bam, in your face.
Zack, weggehämmert.
Alter!
Was geht,
was geht mit ihm denn ab?
Er hat das Game
gelieft dabei oder was?
Also wie er die Transition hier unten
macht, also hier unten, dass er Text
so überblendet,
verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so
ganz. Wie macht er das denn?
Es ist kein jQuery
Animation am Start.
Es ist hier auch nichts drin.
Also wie er die Überblend-Animation
macht, check ich nicht.
Wobei, der navigiert auch nicht
von Seite zu Seite, das ist alles
innerhalb von einer Anwendung.
Jaja, das hat
er alles in Single Page.
Der hat das quasi alles in einer Seite.
Der navigiert gar nicht von einer Seite
zur anderen.
Das ist alles innerhalb von einer Seite.
Naja, ich glaube,
damit können wir leben, dass das
so umswitcht.
Ich würde daraus auch
eine komplette Single Page Application
machen, dann bräuchte ich aber
irgendeinen Vue.js Build Step und
Vue.js Komponenten, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Webpack ist die Ausgeburt
des Bösen.
So Leute, ich gehe jetzt aufs Klo und was
essen.
Ich glaube, wir haben unser Ziel für heute
erreicht. Ich werde das morgen noch
ein bisschen hübsch machen, dann werde ich den beiden schicken.
Dann können sie es ja mal ausprobieren.
Irgendwie weit das tut,
was wir noch einbauen können.
Das ist immer ganz gut, wenn man was gebastelt hat
und das quasi die Leute relativ
früh mal testen lässt. Nicht,
dass man quasi komplett
dran vorbei
baut.
Und wenn das morgen getestet ist,
dann machen wir vielleicht morgen
Mittag oder morgen Abend machen wir noch ein paar Sachen
rein, die aufgefallen sind bei
Kein Problem,
GabiRally. Ich habe es ja hauptsächlich auch
gemacht, da ich was zu bestreben habe.
Aber ich finde, das Interface ist echt ganz nice
geworden. Gefällt mir echt
gut. Habe ich jetzt
schon zehnmal gesagt oder so, aber gefällt mir
trotzdem.
Statistiken, sonst
was.
Paging müssen wir hier noch einbauen. Was wir auch
noch unbedingt einbauen müssen, was da jetzt gar nicht
drin ist, was wahrscheinlich gleich mal
morgen Probleme machen wird, ist,
dass wenn man
Rechner, zwei Rechner zeitgleich
aufbaut, dass dann beide Rechner
sich den gleichen Key grabben.
Wir müssen auch unbedingt so ein Pending-Feld
einführen, dass quasi solange
der zweite Key nur angefragt
ist, aber noch nicht aktiviert,
dass der Key dann nicht an einen zweiten
Rechner rausgegeben wird.
Erst wieder, wenn die Aktivierung
bei dem anderen fehlgeschlagen ist.
Aber zum Testen mit 1, 2
Keys morgen sollte das auch
so hinhauen. So, Leute.
Dann sehen wir uns morgen
wahrscheinlich wieder.
Macht's gut. Bis denn. See you.